Five four, three, two, one, boom,
and we're live with the Oji of ogs.
If there is more of an Oji
MMA character than you,
I don't know who the fuck they
would be more. Who's hoists Gracie,
and that's about as, oh Geez. It
gets right. You know what that means?
What does it mean? You're both fucking
old. We're all, yeah, we're all mood.
I was watching the,
there was a,
the other day was the 20th anniversary
of Dan Henderson's first UFC appearance.
Oh my God, me interviewing
them afterwards. I'm like,
who's that fucking little kid?
You and Dan Hennah just who's Dan
Henderson pretended to be Dan Henderson,
UFC 12 Dothan, Alabama.
You got transferred? Yeah.
What?
We're supposed to go up to buffalo
and they canceled it out of New York.
New York said, get Outta here and we
had to take a puddle jumper plane.
Remember all that jazz really very
well. I was in court. God Damn.
I knew I was in trouble. Yeah,
you were one of the, you mean you,
you were one of the people
that I cite all the time for.
Why that stupid reason
that the 12 to six elbow,
you're the one who just it to me cause I
couldn't believe what you're telling me
was true at the reason 12 to six elbows
were illegal. Well, just tell the story.
The truth of the stories back.
There's so many stories about rules and
how they came about and you know there's
guys claiming things and it's
like, really? Okay. You look at,
I have paperwork that shows how the war,
how things came out and
at what time it was.
And I still have my computers that I
have things written on that we went over
stuff. But you have computers from
the nineties dude, I still have no,
I've got floppy disk. No, you don't
swear to God. He'd do. Unbelievable.
You do with it. How much can a floppy,
this whole, not even like a Manga,
right? Nothing holds a couple
of pages of a document.
But you remember when the floppy
disk went away, everybody panicked.
Like what are you doing?
You fucking taken away the floppy desk.
What are you going to put stuff on that?
When Matt got rid of the floppy disk,
I remember people like these guys are
assholes. Like what are they thinking?
But anyways, when, when the
unified rules, you know,
what happened was everyone
looks at the UFC and says,
oh well you know,
when the UFC went to the first show that
was done in New Jersey was the IFC Paul
Smith's show.
It was done in September,
I want to say 1999 okay.
And the UFC went there
in November of 1999 and,
and yet you have to go back and understand
the history of what was going on.
And this is where I have my issues with
people that try to change history and
rewrite things.
And what was going on was 7,400 team
of group at the time owned the UFC.
That's who you were working,
Bob Meyrowitz Meyrowitz
and Mclaren Campbell.
Mclaren was long gone and you know,
and I love I then by 19 Oh my God. Yes.
He was there when I came around in 97 I
think he hired you. Yeah. And you know,
he did some stuff and he comes up with,
I'm the cocreator the UFC.
You know what, let me just ask one
question. If you're the cocreator,
how come you never owned one
bit of it doesn't make sense.
Doesn't out Campbell Mclaren. Yes.
Dare you. You know what? I'm tired.
Why lie?
He did things and I will,
I will absolutely give him credit for
what he did because he was the reason that
it actually made it to pay per view
because art Davey had gone to everyone.
Prime ticket at the time was a paper view
provider because the paper view world
back then was about 15 million in the u
s it's not like it is now. You know, you,
you were limited,
but prime ticket was one.
Hbo was another and he had
gone to all those and they
all turn no, no, no, no, no.
And there was this one company,
Semafore entertainment group out of New
York that did rock and roll shows and
they did one sporting event.
It was Martina Nevada,
Nevada Lova against Jimmy
Connors and tennis. Oh Wow.
Remake of the remake of the Billie
Jean King Bobby Riggs thing.
Wow, I remember that.
That's crazy. That was them.
I didn't know that was [inaudible].
That was the only sporting thing they'd
ever done before the UFC. But they were,
they were looking for something
that they could rerun and,
and make happen again and again.
And Campbell looked at what
art brought to him and said,
I think this could be that thing.
And Horry and came up with the idea.
Horian Gracie, negative, negative, not
true. He says he came up with the idea.
Are you saying you calling out
Horian Gracie? He not calling
big John doesn't fuck around. Look at
horror. Horror, horror. Ian had his thing.
I love, you know what? I fell
in love with what they did.
That's how I got involved.
Right. But horian are,
Davey went to Horian
because he needed validity.
He needed somebody to give actual value
and some credence to what he was trying
to do because he went to
Horace Mann off of, uh, uh,
there was an article in Playboy
magazine, bad, you know,
and it was about Horian.
And you know, at this guy,
this family that would fight anybody.
And you know Chad,
it was a bad article
that would called back.
That was the actual title
B a d across two pages.
Bad was the, I remember we had a article,
I don't remember that part about it,
but it was,
it was basically they were offering like
a lot of money to fight anybody. Right.
It went well. It was the whole thing
of the hundred thousand dollar check,
but he didn't have $100,000,
you know, and so it was,
well if you bring $100,000 I'll put up
a hundred no one's bringing $100,000.
Right. So just more like a
publicity stunt. Yeah, they did.
Obviously they had the Gracie challenge
before that and they did all the Gracie
in action tapes that we'd all seen.
Yup.
And he'd see all these karate
masters it down, strangled, you
know, and that was, that was the thing
that I loved the fact when, you know,
I can go through the whole thing of how
I met Horian but when I met him there
was never anything
about, well you know, we,
we would do this and that situation but
we can't do that cause will hurt you or
something like that was what happened
in a lot of martial arts all,
well we can't do that because that
would really, that will hurt you,
that will kill you. And he was
like, let's do it right. Every time.
And that's what I fell in love with.
It's like, hey, they're not phony.
They're real. Right. Yeah.
And the first time I ever did anything
with them all hoists Gracie arm barred me
and I went, how did you do that? And
then I just fell in love with it.
A lot of people said that
about hoists Gracie. Yeah.
Those early days of the UFC was,
boy, I mean you want to talk about,
I mean he really played it out perfectly
because he really was the best version
of explaining Jujitsu.
Like what did,
how did he show the effectiveness of
Jujitsu? Well, here's what you do.
You'll lock some dudes
in a cage with no rules,
guides bigger than him and he's
wearing his geeky. So he looks,
he's the only one that looks like,
like what we think of as a martial artist,
right?
And you get these guys,
everyone else looks like big old street
thugs that jacked up on steroids.
They're giant and they're
running after him.
And we always would think of like Bruce
Lee in these martial artists who it
technique over size and they would beat
all these people, but in the real world,
that shit didn't work. Nope.
It just didn't work. Bigger
guys always fucked you up.
They were heavier. He hit him. It
didn't work. It bounced off of them.
That got you on the ground.
They punched your face in.
But all of a sudden there was this
little guy wasn't little, but you know,
it was 175 pounds in comparison
to the rest of the people.
He was fairly small and he's tapping guys
at triangles off his back and arm bar
and people and, and everybody with
greatest, greatest infomercial ever.
It was the greatest. Exactly. Got me on
board. I mean to me and everybody else,
man, all these people that like me
came from a striking background.
I was like Holy Shit. And that's like,
this is crazy. That's where I look at.
Horian was brilliant because he listened
to what art said and goes and so whose
idea was it? It was art. It was art idea
to have a bunch of guys fight. Absolutely.
100% well how much did art,
how much of the art owner that he owned a,
I want to say basically 25%
20 when they sold it to,
cause they had zoomba he got a piece of
that. Oh well no, he was, he was gone.
Gone it before that you've got to
figure when there was two there was wow.
Promotions and wild promotions came from
war of the worlds because art had named
the whole competition or the world.
Ah.
And then Semafore entertainment group
changed it to the ultimate fighter.
I vaguely remembered that whole thing.
Guy Named Michael Abrams is the
one that named it. So it when,
when art had with Horian he gave Horian
25% he had 25% and Bob Myerwitz own 50%
because of putting it on paper
view.
Ah,
so you had while promotions owning 50%
Semafore for entertainment group owning
50% and actually wow.
Owned a little bit less because they
had brought together investors and they
were trying to get $250,000 and they got
somewhere around 115,000 and $12,000 of
investment that they put up cause that
was going to be part of the money for the
people that we're competing in it.
It's crazy.
When you think about what it is now,
this is where we're talking about 1993
what new sport can you think of other
than MMA from 1993 that's
now a huge global force.
I mean, it is something that everybody
talks about globally. Nothing.
The one thing that you
can look at and say, wow,
that that's really gained traction.
American Ninja Warrior. Oh yeah.
But it's not right. It's an
athletic competition. Yeah,
it's a show that
definitely gained traction.
That's a fun fucking show it dude.
How fun that show was.
I didn't ever watched it until like a
year ago. Those people are incredible.
Oh yeah.
As far as athletes and the ability to,
I mean just the grip strength cause
you know everyone thinks that,
oh you can hang on a bar forever.
No you can't.
We learned in fear factor that girls
are better at that than guys because
Holly's body weight, I wouldn't
have believed it. I looked at this,
well we have this one guy in
the show that was jacked, big,
thick old dude and there was girls
that were like, you know, 125 pounds,
hundred 30 pounds and this guy was,
he was toast it like a minute and 30
seconds he was done and these girls were
hanging in there. I was
like, this is crazy.
This is really interesting because I
would think the girls' hands were weak,
I would think. Nope.
Because it's, it's a matter,
the only difference that
you can make it as you,
you take change the size of the bar and
start making the bar bigger. Oh yeah.
It starts to have more of an advantage
because of his hand being bigger. Right,
right. But that will take the
advantage away from the girl.
Cause now she's actually starting to cup
over it or finger strength starts to go
before I, yeah. So, um, yeah, so MMA who,
who named it mixed martial
arts, you know, that's a,
that's a whole story. And you're going
to hear, I heard it was you. Well I,
I give credit to Jeff Blatnick
as far as look at, ah,
he didn't come up with the term who did,
but the truth,
and this is the first thing I can
tell you, I wrote, I wrote a, uh,
I had to do it what's called a work
permit for LAPD because I worked for LAPD
back in 1993, 93, [inaudible] 94.
And it was because I was going
to referee this second UFC,
which was March 11th of 1994
and for me to actually work,
the department has to allow me to,
I have to ask for permission,
and then they have to
grant that permission.
Was there a concern that
it was too outrageous?
So that was part of the whole
thing is I didn't want to say, Oh,
I've got two guys going into a cage,
they're going to beat the
shit out of each other. So the
first thing I put was martial
arts referee. Hmm, okay.
And then they said, well,
what kind of martial arts?
So I wrote mixed martial arts referee.
Now I can tell you that that was in 90
right at the end of 93 [inaudible] not a
term.
I didn't get it from anywhere other than
I'm sitting there trying to think of,
but I do know that there was a columnist,
a sports writer from the La Times
that wrote about the very first UFC,
and in his article wrote mixed martial
arts. Ah, so maybe it was Hansel.
Well, you've got John [inaudible].
He's saying that he's, you know,
he did it back in 1983 it's like,
okay, well if no one's saying it,
it doesn't mean shit. Okay.
So the truth of the matter is,
so Peretti might have said it, he might've
said it, but it didn't mean anything.
Right. Because the fact of the matter
is, and it doesn't matter what I wrote,
what matters is when, you
know, and when you joined it,
when you joined the UFC,
it was still considered no holds barred.
NHB Yeah. He was what we called.
And it was something that was,
and this is probably part
of my problem with Campbell.
Mclaren is back at you before UFC too,
you know,
they had them on Good Morning America
with Jim Brown and you go back to that and
he came up with the line that
you could win by knockout,
tap out or death.
Okay.
And four years after that,
I was in court having that thrown in my
face by the fricking attorneys trying to
put us down saying, isn't this
what you are companies? No,
that's not what my cock fighting.
That's what an idiot said. Yeah. Okay.
And so he still to this day things,
he was magnificent with that.
But you look and you go might have been
in terms of buying it drew attention,
it drew attention.
There's no doubt.
But when we were trying to combat that,
we were trying to get away from no
holds barred because the whole no holds
barred met. There's no
rules. And there was a rule.
But the thing is it's
still no holds barred.
I mean you could do inside heel
hooks, you could do the MNR, he choke,
you can do whatever you want holds
in terms of holes. That's true.
It's like it came from wrestling, right?
Absolutely. Wrestling there was it? No,
I mean bars in amateur wrestling, there
was things you couldn't do, right?
There's certain head box you
couldn't do in wrestling comp.
You have to have an arm in and instead
of having just the neck holds barred,
so no holds barred. It's essentially
still and HB, but they're, you know,
but back then it was,
was there eye gouging ever?
No, never. The very first set of
rules for the first UFC. And you know,
and this is again, you know
there's people saying, oh,
I came up with the five minute round.
It's like you're a fucking liar. Sorry,
you aren't calling everybody.
I'm tired of fricking sitting there
having people lie because there's a lot of
people out there that come up
with stuff and you go, really?
I can prove that wrong when you're
talking about five minute rounds,
the very first
had three rules, no
eye gouging, no biting,
no groin strikes,
everything else was allowed.
When did groin strikes
coming to the picture though?
Because everybody remembers Keith
Hackney and Joe Song. Okay, hold on.
So that was cool.
That was UFC one and it was
unlimited five minute rounds.
Wasn't Keith Hackney chosen?
You see four, yeah. Okay. Yeah,
this is now,
this one was unlimited,
unlimited five minute rounds,
but no fight went the five minutes.
The longest one was two
minutes and 30 seconds. Right?
So after the first UFC,
the Semafore looked and said,
well,
why are we having rounds when none of the
fights? We're going that long anyways.
And so we're just going to take the round
thing away so we don't have any stop
in the action. And then there was
certain fighters, Zane Frazier being,
you know,
the main ones saying if I could have need
to the groin like I would in my system
and what I do, it would have been
a completely different fight.
And they went and said, okay, you can knee
to the groin, you can hit to the groin.
No eye gouging. No biting. That
was UFC too. That was the rules.
Wow.
So no eye gouging,
no biting and no time on it's
UFC to no time limits. Wow.
It's just so crazy to think that
this is a giant sport that's on Fox.
It's on ESPN. It's a huge paper view
force. You hear about it all the time.
You have a, a real group of
experts wearing suits and ties,
discussing techniques that,
I mean,
when you sit down and watch the foc
panel and you see like Tyron Woodley and
Michael Bisbing,
Paul Felder,
and everybody's sitting there discussing
technique and strategy and they need to
thank people from the past. That
crap in there. Yeah. I mean,
you go back and watch some of the old
school shit where the sumo guy got his
tooth kicked into the spine. That
got me my job. Did it really? Yeah.
That fight right there. That's how
I got my job. What happened? Well,
Horian and brought in two guys.
He brought in Leo Vizio from Brazil,
who is a, he's famous as being
the death squad cop down in Rio.
And they brought in a guy
named [inaudible] [inaudible]
and [inaudible] was the
referee for that very first fight between
Taylor Tulia and Gerardo and drug or
doe. Who was that gentleman that
he could, he blinded a guy. Oh,
you're talking about in cow.
Cow.
Cow Eventually went on to fight Hixson
Hixson Hixson wouldn't punch him because
of his eye. He knew is I
was all fucked up. You know,
there's been a couple of
fights where I can tell you,
you hoist had a fight and uh,
you go back and watch it.
You'll see he doesn't punch somebody
because his father told him,
don't punch him. Yeah. You know,
and that's part of that was part
of like even the Gracie challenges.
I can tell you back when, you
know, even I did a couple, it was,
they would tell you,
you know,
Horian was big into you want to come
into the school, you want to do this.
If he didn't think the
person had that much talent,
he would put a student against him.
He would never put one of his brothers
if he thought the guy was actually good,
he put his brother right.
And you know,
one of the things they would tell you
is hey, take him down. Choke him out.
Armbar don't, don't hit him. Right.
And afterwards they would go and tell
the person, you know, hey, you know,
what do you think? You know,
do you believe, you know,
and if the person who you know wanted
to try again, they would hit him,
beat him now fuck heard him yell back.
And that was okay.
So you would know this then.
What is the story about Hixon
not being in the first UFC?
Cause everybody knows
everybody that knows you. Just,
who knows that Hixon is widely
regarded as the greatest of all time.
Like when it comes to the Gracies,
when it comes to anybody of that error,
Hickson was the fucking man. Hands
down. You ask anybody still is the map.
But isn't it crazy? It's still as the mat.
But if you ask anybody, no one said Nah,
it was Ricardo the barrio or Nah,
it was this guy.
Everybody went Hixon how fucking
good do you have to be? Exactly.
Everybody agrees. That's how lucky
I was. I got to the, he was my,
he was my instructor. Isn't that
crazy? It's crazy because you know,
you look in you and it,
and this is the whole thing of this is
what people don't understand and I hear
it guys now and it's like, God damn, are
you that stupid? Because there's a wall.
I think that, you know, so
and so could beat him down.
It's like that's a decent 60 years
old. It did. But not only that,
it's a different world now.
Exactly what Hickson was.
He was so advanced in comparison to
everybody else physically because he had
figured out yoga.
He had figured out breathing and
meditation and physical strength.
He was incredibly flexible.
I'm sure you've seen those exercises
he did on the balancing beam where he's
standing on a balancing beam with one
leg doing a full split in the air,
holding his foot up in the air full
split and he had physical abilities that
were you just unparalleled.
He had a muscular dearth we use,
he used to do just an exercise class.
Okay.
Back in 91 or so and he
would do one leg at Pike's,
swung down one leg, kick your
leg out. He would do that.
He had a muscular endurance.
He would do 51 legged pikes.
I mean, and I would, I was dying. I
mean I was like, that's incredible.
In a row in a row.
He was,
he would just keep going and
people guys were falling out.
I was falling out and everybody and
he just keeps going and going and go,
what are you made of? Well, he just
had unbelievable discipline and, and,
and also like, and just an understanding
of his body, you know, I mean,
his, his whole thing was he said
he was so basic. Joe, you know,
his Jujitsu, you look at guys
now and you know what I mean?
And then you look at like Eddie,
I love it.
I love guys that are innovators and
you know, there's all kinds of people.
There's always going to be
someone that's a naysayer.
I look at Eddie Bravo
and go, man, you are,
you're the guy who, you know, and he,
you say perfect all the time where
he's got a, his Ninja, the Ninja Geeks,
you know,
all these guys that are just geeky guys
at are killers in Jujitsu now.
They're nerd assassins.
Exactly what you, and it's
the truth. Yeah. But Eddie's,
that guy that he's calm,
he looked at things just different
than other guys and how can I do this
different?
And that's how Jujitsu started for,
as far as Brazilian Jujitsu with
Leo. Sure. Hickson was the guy.
He was so basic as far as what he did,
but he was so precise.
His ability to create a pressure and the
only guy that I've seen do it sometimes
the same way as Damien
Maia. Yeah. You know,
it was Hixon could create a pressure that
was just like where the what is on top
of it. And when you
say basic, here's like,
some people think that's an
insult like no, remember,
but Vinnie McCullough has said that about
Minataro says Jiu Jitsu is very basic
and,
and got really upset and I wouldn't eat,
I wouldn't say that that is inaccurate,
but it's not that Minataro is arguably
one of the greatest Jujitsu fighters of
all time as far as MMA goes. I mean,
what he did for Jujitsu when he,
when he armbar Bob Sapp,
I mean Holy Shit,
when he triangle Mark Coleman and all
those different guys that he tapped out
over in pride,
you got to see basic Jujitsu meaning the,
the things that everybody knows like
triangles, armbars, chokes, desert basics.
It doesn't mean it's like simple or dumb.
No,
it's a basic is actually like to have
the basics are everything and crone kicks
in.
Sun Crone is got that same style of you
use it but yet is a world champion with
it.
I mean there's something to be said for,
it's like that old Bruce Lee expression
don't fear man that knows 10,000 kicks.
Fear Man has practiced one kick
10,000 times. Exactly. Yeah.
There's something to having a precision
of those techniques that just you and
everybody knows what an arm, I mean Haji
Haji, Gracie it same thing to this day.
Basic basic style crushes everything you
could want and one one of my favorite
Jujitsu matches to watch is Gary
Tonin against chrome grace. Yeah.
It was part of master was holy
Shit is the difference of the more,
this is a guy that masters basics to
the guy that's trying all kinds of
different things now and really
going after you look at Gordon Ryan,
look at Craig Jones, look at these guys,
look at what they're doing. Yeah, that's,
this is the John Danaher effect though.
Like well dean lister and
then John Donahoe. You know,
Dean lister are saying it to John Don her,
why would you ignore 50%
of the human body? Dude,
he said the same thing to me at one time.
It's like Whoa, damn, why would you,
I never thought of that.
Yeah, and that crazy truth.
But isn't it crazy that like one little
statement like that can change Jujitsu?
Cause if you look at what's going on now,
like leg locks are just
out of control now.
Everybody's leg lock
in people and you want,
and you're watching the progression of
guys from leg locking people in Jujitsu
to leg locking people.
Now in MMA,
Dylan Dennis the other day
with that foot lock told,
told you watching the Nieman
Gracie he had, you watched him,
he's controlling both legs up. You got
a problem, right? Know he didn't get,
he made a mistake in it and
that's, you know, hey we can,
we all make a mistake and I didn't
catch that when to shit a troll.
Those two legs
see fighters not understanding
how to get themselves out.
And so this is, there's
your next progression. Yup.
You better learn that if you don't know
that you're going to be in trouble,
you know? And that is the
Danaher effect. He is a genius.
It's just fascinating
too. But you know, these,
these techniques that we're talking about,
like there's guys though that
can even shut those down.
I mean guys who have those understanding
of the basics that can shut, I mean,
I would really like to see hogger.
I mean, I know Hodges retiring,
which is unfortunate. I mean
fortunate and unfortunate. I get it.
He's arguably one of the greatest rappers
of all time without a doubt. Yeah.
And uh, I would like to see him
though against like a Gordon. Ryan,
wouldn't you want to see that? Like of
course. I mean they're both big guys.
They're both very strong and Hodgett
with that extreme basic game.
The old school. So are you going to
say would win it? I would never say no.
Fuck knows. I want to ask it. That's
the whole point. That's why you look at,
and you get all these all so, and would
wait. Oh, you know what? That's why you,
that's why I always liked lock guys that
went and trained with Braulio esteem
steamer and he shut that shit down and
they were like, whoa. And they were like,
okay,
there's something,
there's something to be said for that
intense pressures style, that solid,
get those things that you used to do.
That's where I'm really interested
in with look it, you know,
people don't realize how good Rafael
Lovato Junior, oh, how could you not? Oh,
how could you not?
Cause they're not guys that
actually live in the Jujitsu world.
They live only in the MMA world.
And he fights for Bella to where
he can't be any good. And you know,
he's one of the best in the
world. Oh my God. You know,
and Gerald Harris is a tough
guy. Oh, he's a tough guy.
Cheryl Harris is very strong,
very good wrestler.
He was 25 and he's now 25 and six. Look
at, he has beaten some good people.
He's got four slam Kaos is a monster
in certain areas of the fight.
And you look and you go,
that was the way that Rothfield
switched that arm. And the w and the,
just the control of the lights. Cause
you see the leg, his head's getting up,
he brings that you can look and you go
to have, you realize how good that is.
Yeah. Well for a guy like you as a
black belt in Jujitsu, you see that?
That's like you're watching
an art. It is art and, and,
and I tell people all the time, look at,
yeah I can. I used to be able to roll.
I can roll with that guy.
That dude is world class.
There's a level of like, I was trying
to explain this to someone who's like,
well you're a black belt too. I'm like,
that guy would treat me like a white belt.
Like I'm a blue belt.
Like I'm just a beginner.
There's lots of fat and that's
the whole town. It's like,
why are you going to sit there and try
it so I could roll it. No, there's facts.
Like if you don't know
Jujitsu and you're my size,
I'm going to choke the shit out.
You're going to crush a chance.
But if you're a Marcello Garcia,
you could be 30 pounds lighter than me
and I'm fucked. I have zero chance. Yep.
You have to just say, explain. It's a
bit like you have no chance. I'm like,
listen to me. I am defending the
entire time. Yeah, I got zero chance.
I'm defending up until he gets me. It's
not a matter of if he's going to get me,
it's when is he going to get the matter?
I'm helpless.
When do I make that mistake that he
goes, but yeah, when you slap hands,
you're admitting you're a victim.
I'm a victim.
Just let's just try to keep me from
being a victim as long as I can.
There's just levels and when you roll
with a guy like John Jacques Machado or
you know, any high level
person, you feel that extreme.
That's just like the
precision and technique. It's,
it's amazing to feel and experience
because from the outside looking in,
if you don't know Jujitsu,
you can't see it. You don't,
you don't know what you're looking at.
That's what we,
it's like when you say you're John,
John, you feel from the moment you start,
I'm in danger. Yeah, there's no,
and then finally you'll get to the
point where you can go, you can lock in,
you can pinch down and people are like,
what? We'll do something. It's like, dude,
I am doing stuff.
I have survivor.
I had dinner with Hixon
once and Hickson and crone.
And then we went back to the house.
It was amazing.
And went back to the house and we put out,
he put on fights and he was breaking
down fights for me and talking about like
errors people were making and
he was talking about space.
That's what he kept talking about.
Look at all this space,
look at all this space between, oh, this,
oh, this movement to space equals a scab.
And then you'd watch him and there
was the Colosseum fight, you know?
And Yeah, when he fought for
[inaudible] and that was his last fight.
And when he fought would knock,
you see this just crushing game
where he just gets a hold. I mean,
once he's got you, you're
not, and he explained it to
me, I'll never forget this.
He goes, he goes, we started a neutral
point. We started zero. He goes,
and when we go to one,
we're not going back to zero.
We're going to two and then two, three
and then we'll shut me. She's like,
we're not going backwards. We're
going full. And you're like, Jesus,
I'm scared. I want to run home. Puts you.
You go on your watch that you
know and people don't work.
People don't realize how good
food knock he actually was.
Who knocked it was a beast.
He was the big test for Hixon every
and he crushed Hickson's orbital,
remember punch it broke.
It broke his orbital cause I mean he
was a real sort of one punch can do and
Funai was a real threat and hips and
put him to snarky was a guy as far as
grappling in Japan,
he,
you can go on and again it's
that size thing because he was,
he was a good size 200 and
plus 10 to 15 pounds jacked,
jacked and a good grappler who,
you know,
you can go back and look at all the
guys from the past and you know,
the Satos and everybody that
were phenomenal, they all said,
well no one can beat him.
He was that good Hixon to steroid
just once it hit the ground yet.
But that's like,
it was almost like I was talking with
Jay Glazer before the Dillon data's fight
know I'm Dylan is in is, you know,
this is his first fight. And yes,
he's saying a lot of
stuff. I love that. Hey,
you got to have confidence in yourself.
Okay. And you've got to put it out there.
But you know, Jay has asked me, he
says, he goes, what can I
say? I said, look at, this is
what you can say about him.
It is his first fight.
I go,
but if he gets his hands around
his opponent and they do this,
it's over. He will not get out.
His opponent will not survive.
He is that good on the ground.
And you know, it's, uh, it's,
it's so hard to get people to
realize how good certain people are,
you know? And just there, you know,
obviously if you get hit and your
brain's not working because your brain is
everything that can be taken
away to a point from you.
But if your brain is there and
you have that submission ability,
you're always dangerous.
Yeah. It's, uh, it's just, it's to me,
the most enjoyable thing to watch because
it's so complex because there's so
many variables and it's so interesting,
so much going on in a fight.
There's just so much happening,
so many possibilities, you know?
And for you as a referee,
I mean, you've had, I mean,
I always say I had the best seat in the
house next to you, cause I did. I mean,
you've got to sit down. We'll be,
it's better you could get around me.
You can look at all the best
places from a foot away. I mean,
you were, you were there for all of it,
man. You got to be there. Well, I mean,
do you the only one,
really the only one that truly experienced
those fights without some sort of a
barrier in between them.
True. I'm going to go back real quick
for you. Okay. So it, so it goes,
how did Hixon not get to fight in UFC one?
That was the question. We didn't
answer the question. Yeah.
So we have two questions to answer this.
12 to six elbow,
but let's go to this. Why, why
wasn't Hixon? Because Hixon was the,
the champion of the family.
Oh, no. Dot. By far. Any,
even back then hoist came
out in articles and said,
my brother Hixon is 10 times better than
me. Oh, always said that he wasn't lying.
He said, I will go to train tonight and
my brother would tap me a hundred times.
You, you're so good at them. But
what truly happened was,
again, I, and I say,
look at the first UFC for Horian
horian looked at this entire thing.
People have to understand how whore,
how much time Horian had spent.
Trying to get people to understand
grappling is an art form.
That taking somebody down and putting
them into a place where they are unaware
of what can happen to them.
You know,
unknowledgeable is a way for
you to be safe in a fight,
taking kinetic energy off of their plate
and putting you in a place where you
could do what you do. And he was
trying to sell this the whole time.
Then he meets Art Davy or Davies,
the one that helps put together the
Gracie in action tapes and through that
marketing scheme Horry and sees this guy
can make me money. And so then he does,
he says, okay, look, what are you
talking about with your fighting thing?
And no doubt Hixon is the
best one in the family,
but Hixon at that time is
training people out of Torrance.
And then he opens
up his own studio in west La. He go, yes.
And when he opened up his, his studio
in west La Hora and went, what,
you're not going to I,
the person that is going to be fighting
in this is going to be representing my
school.
And that's how hoists got it.
And so that was always the rumors that
he couldn't control Hixon couldn't. Yeah.
The other rumor was there was two rumors,
one that you couldn't control Hickson
and the other one was that Hickson was
like physically very impressive
and that they, that's such a lot.
This is a lie. It's a lie. And
let me just go ahead a sentence.
The sentence was that because
he was physically impressive,
it wouldn't be as good an advertisement
for Jujitsu because hoist was like long
and thin and he wasn't like the typical
but Hickson when you looked at him like
with his shirt off,
I mean a six pack and big muscles.
He looked like a
physically impressive guy.
But Pixton was 100 he was 10 pounds
heavier than hoists. Yeah. Okay.
Little bit shorter. Yeah, shorter than
hoist. But he would've worn the, you know,
if he would have worn the g, what are
you going to see anyways? Right. Nothing.
Okay. It looks, you know,
guidance g and you know,
that whole thing of Horian
marketing wise said,
oh it was because Hixon is
this big guy and you know,
I wanted to more insane
when he came out with that.
So he said that just because he needed
an excuse for why he couldn't control his
accent. Yup. So us as
Jujitsu practitioners, I,
I started doing Jujitsu in
[inaudible] 96 with Hixon.
I started Hixon school on Pico.
Yeah. Louis Heredia my first class.
And uh,
but then I took a couple classes there,
but then I found out the cross in Glee
Gracie's was closer to my house in La.
I didn't know Jack Shit.
No, it, his was, yeah,
his was on a hawthorn right off
of a write off of La Cienega. Oh.
So it was right down the street from
the comedy store. So it was like, well,
this is like near where I live this
way. And I was like, Gracie is Gracie.
I didn't know there was any difference
between the two of them. And then I,
and Carlson Gracie was always on a John
Perretti show when John Perretti had
that extreme was extreme
combat or challenge extremes,
challenge battle Cade battle
Kate. Right. And so I said,
well I'll just go train here.
So I stopped training with literally
the greatest of all time, you know,
cause I didn't know any better.
But you went to training with the
guy that would hold nothing back.
Everything. Well also I went there
while v Tor was still victor.
Yeah, he was Victor Gracie. They
called him Victor Gracie. In fact,
like when I first interviewed,
I called him victor a couple times because
we had always called him victor and
they were calling a victor Gracie,
but he was getting sued by Horian was
saying that you can't use the Gracie name.
And so he had to stop calling himself
Gracie and he was going with Belfort and
Mario Sperry was there.
There was like,
I mean that was a Carlos
by Hato was there. Yeah.
But it was a fucking crazy place to be.
If you think about the history of
Jujitsu and MMA, I mean it was,
it was an amazing time to, have you ever
been to his original school in Rio? No.
No. And I'm God man. I, it's like you
look at, it's a dungeon. It's ups.
It's an upstairs dungeon. But I
mean you look and you go, oh my God,
all these guys learn in. It's, it's,
it's a room. It's actually this size,
this size right here.
And you think about the guys that he
had there and one retired army but Tesh,
a Carter Laborio by head toe.
Alan goes all these guys and you go man,
that and the one thing out of all of them,
cause you know,
I'm at least I've been lucky enough to
be able to know all of them and talk to
him and train with a lot of women.
All of them would man Carlson, Gracie,
I love him. He's my father. He
never held anything back from me.
And you've got to look and you go.
That was the thing because I remember I
had some friends that went to Torrance
and right after hoists tapped
out Dan seven with a triangle.
They wanted to learn the triangle
and they were saying, no,
you're not ready for that yet.
You're not ready for that already.
And Mario Sperry was teaching
us like right off the bat,
oh Mario Sperry's explaining,
I'll never forget this is explaining how
it used to practice triangles with his
girlfriend.
He's making his girlfriend sit there
and he would just rotate on or just left
triangle, right triangle, left triangle,
right track and he would
just practice on it.
That's a good relationship right there.
While I was a good woman, I tell you,
because my wife would go, fuck you. Yeah,
good woman looks just sync up trying a
lot of over and over and over again. Yeah.
You know, he would just rotate
his hips if he's saying,
if you can get someone that's the
best way to work in your triangle.
He was saying,
if you can get someone,
it's really just about doing those numbers
over and over and over and over again.
So he was teaching us
that right off the bat.
So that that is a thing about Carlson.
But you crossed that place went under,
went under somewhere around 98 and that's
when I moved over to John Jock and I
started training John Jackson since 98
you didn't miss a beat there though. No.
So got lucky too.
At the time I,
I had just started to understand
who John Jock was and,
but everybody wanted that Gracie name,
which is why you know a lot of guys
went with Gracie as their last name,
even though it wasn't a last name.
Still to this day,
even Hodges Hodges last name.
And he said it's not his mom's last name.
Same with Neiman. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You
don't even, his last name is strong.
Belsky oh,
what's wrong with that?
It's weird that that's still last name,
but his mom comes from the grassy side.
That's crazy that you mean the dad must
be like, what in the fuck? It's my name.
What's my name, kid. Um, that
was, that was always a thing.
But then I started to understand
Jiu Jitsu. Then, you know,
I'd been doing it for a little while
and then everybody had heard about John
John Machado and he can Machado
and the brothers and John.
And it was one of those than
hydro. And we knew that, okay,
this is another family that's also
like an elite world class family.
And then we started training and there
was people saying at the time of all the
materials aren't as good as a Gracie. So
you go, Oh yes they are. They're the same.
Well there was, there's just
high level, right? Yeah.
There's so much of it today.
And John Joc is the guy,
you look at all of them cause you know,
if you're going to go on you,
you're going to say,
well who was the best if they
train between each other,
it was Hagan.
He was a monster because he was so big,
so strong and his Jujitsu
was really fricking good.
Well there's a great match for
Jean Hagen and Hixon. Absolutely.
Watch black and white. Yeah.
Can Wild Shit from, you know,
and he can doing good
for a lot of that sucker.
But you look at the guy that technically
how just different he was in the red,
it was John Jock.
Well one of the things is that John Jack
was born with a deformity where he only
has a thumb on one hand but that's
lefthand, doesn't have any fingers.
So because of that,
a lot of people credit John Joc with a
lot of the over hooks and under hooks
that really tend to
dominate no geek grappling.
Cause John Jack was not grabbing
the g with that left hand.
Look at him when in ADCC. Yes. What he's
doing and look what he can't grab in the,
but he was taken and putting his hands
in ways and you look and you go, it is,
look at what he's doing.
All of those holds that he's grabbing
and controlling that person with that
instead of the g.
That's what we use today.
Well that's where Eddie learned a lot
of his technique. Let Eddie, you know,
obviously at,
he's a black belt under the John Jack,
but he learned a lot of
his Nogi principles from
John John Because John Jack
couldn't rely on the gate and that's
what we always talked about this.
One of the things that happens to these
gay guys when they come over to MMA,
if they rely too much on the Guid,
they, they have like half their game,
like maybe half the game. It's one
of those things that, you know,
back in the day it was always
all you must train in the key.
You gotta train the gate. Bullshit.
It's not true. Absolutely not. Say this.
He's like, if you want to get good
at tennis, do you play racquetball?
Well then it's exactly, yeah, and this is
the point when I talk about Eddie, I go,
you know, Eddie was saying that
long before anybody else. He's like,
I don't believe that you have to do
train the gear. You have to train.
And it's like, oh no, to learn these.
And it's like most of those don't
work if they're not wearing the right.
There's some,
there's some things about the
[inaudible] that are really good defense.
You have to have real
defense with the gate.
You have to really understand is that
you can't just muscle out of shit.
Well that's the big difference is the
geeky takes away that explosion blowgun
and power and slippery makes you
technically have to do it. Yes. Yes.
There's definitely benefits to the goal.
Yeah. And it's also great for old guys.
You can grab a hold of shit and cling
and hang on and that's all you do. You,
you have some serious neck injuries.
Right. And you're all fused up now, right?
I'm a mess. What did, what'd
they do to you all about?
I'm me say four years ago I had
two disc replace because I, uh,
it was actually,
the dis was broken and it was pressing
in on my spinal cord and I had only like
about it. Eighth of an inch. Between
the touching the other side. No, no, no.
My spinal cord touching the other side,
which would have been
me going kitchen falling
down and not getting back up.
Whoa. So they took an they,
uh,
they relieve the pressure,
took that out and put two fake disc and
put this cage around it to a cause I
didn't want to be fused. I
was panicked about, I look at,
I need to be able to move my neck,
you know, even for refereeing,
it was even more past the Jujitsu,
but I want her to still be
able to do things and rolling
and stuff. And then, uh,
I got hurt in July of
last year bat and it was,
I wasn't like son, you know,
someone meant to do it.
I was training somebody and having
them put a Darce choke on me.
It was no big deal, but they were
doing it wrong as I'm watching him.
So I get down and said, look and put
it on me. Okay, here, put this here.
I don't know. I want you to wait here.
All right. Start putting pressure to,
and I was probably in it for 90 seconds
because I'm talking through it and you
know, and I'm waiting for them to
increase the pressure increase in,
make it tighter. And finally it gets
to where, hey, it's tight. Okay.
And I tapped him and he said,
good. All right, you got it.
And I didn't feel anything,
but that broke the five through seven
in my disc and pushed him out the next
day. I had, he didn't feel it while
it was happening. Did not feel it.
When it happens. Scary shit
about neck injury. It is.
It's like you don't think you really
had an injury because you're like,
I don't remember anything happening.
There was no pain.
I can re I remember cracking when they're
putting it on it because my neck is,
you know, getting, but that's normal
in a, yeah. And so it was like,
that's no big deal. Right.
You're used to it. And men,
the next day I had this fire going down
my arm into my fingers that didn't stop.
And it was like, holy, I mean
pain. Oh yeah. And I mean,
it was,
if you've ever had a stinger from football
or smashing your head into something
and you get that fire, that goes down. And
it did not, I mean, I, from that point,
I didn't sleep.
I was in trouble.
I ended up going and I go in and
they say, ah, you've crushed this.
And so then they went and looked and when
they were supposed to do the surgery,
they were going to fuse from five to
seven. I said, all right, whatever.
And they do that. Well, my body itself
fused around the cage. He's that.
They'd put the disc in.
So I'm fused from three down to seven now.
So it's all good. I can move a little
bit. I can, I can't remember back.
I can, I can turn it to the sides of
the aisle so I'm good. And so three,
where's that start? It starts at the
neck at the top of the head. Right.
Just to down off of the where
your head and your neck attach.
They're doing a lot of
those artificial discs.
Eddie's got one now and he's got an
artificial titanium moving disc. Yeah,
I got to his lower back. You
got those two? I got those.
And those wrapped up in the cage or,
and it's wrapped up in that cage,
which is now fused.
So they're not doing anything except
they're keeping me from getting shorter
again. Jesus Christ. Yeah. Eddie gained
an inch there. You go in at five,
eight to five nine you will, it's not bad
cause man, I'll tell you what, you know,
it's everything with grappling and
Jujitsu smushes those militias you get.
I've gotten,
I've gotten
a lot shorter. Yeah,
it's, it's definitely,
and people will say things
like disc degeneration,
disease. I'm like, slow down.
You're getting injured.
Okay.
You're getting injured over and over
and over again and your district getting
compressed.
And it's not a coincidence that this disc
degenerating disease is happening with
grapplers in the exact same spots,
lower back and the neck and it's
all from getting cranked on it.
It's from getting good team Darst and
fighting your way out of chokes and from
your lower back from being in the guard.
And there's just so much going on.
There's so much going on with your back.
And very few people do anything
to strengthen their back.
I implore people that are doing Jujitsu.
I want you to look at two things,
three things. One, the
reverse hyper machine. That's
that Louie Simmons machine.
I'm sure you know about that. That
fucking thing is so good. Dr Neil Riordan,
the stem cell doctor that I had on before,
he was having some back issues.
He just sent me a picture of uh,
the one of them that he has now and his
place after he came here and saw mine,
he got one of those reverse hypers
put it in his office. He's like,
Jesus Christ is things changed my
body. It's like changed my back. It's,
it's helped me so much. It's
incredible. That thing's amazing.
And then there's a thing called
the iron neck. The iron neck,
which is just a phenomenal
training tool for your neck,
gives you more range of motion
and strengthens your neck.
So many guys just don't do that. You
just train, you just always train.
You got to treat your body
like it's like you are,
you're in the pit stop and you're
in a fucking NASCAR crew, you know,
and you've got to fix stuff and replace
stuff and make sure everything's tuned
up and tighten up and three your body.
Like you got to strengthen all that shit.
Question where you were you that way when
you were 25 though. That was a retard.
There you go. This man stand still.
I can't believe how stupid I am.
That's amazing.
I've gotten so far.
That's the differences when you know I
don't care if you think you're vulnerable,
you're absolutely,
no one can do anything to you.
You know you can't be beat you a,
you can put up with anything. Yup.
And you get into your oldest,
go fuck it. Who Cares?
I'll just train the other side.
I'll just saw, I'll go light.
And you never go like, yeah. And then
you wind up having all these injuries.
It never really healed
themselves and they're like,
one of the best things that ever happened
to me training was something actually
breaking.
Like I'd have an actual torn ACL.
Well now I can't train
for six months for sure.
So now it gives everything a chance
to recuperate and actually heal.
And Like I look, my elbow
doesn't hurt anymore. I was like,
there's all these things.
Like I went,
I told you I got stem cell shots
in my shoulder. The guy goes,
you had a shoulder separation at
some point in time. I'm like, really?
I don't even know. No,
because he gets hurt so much
cranking you in an Americana or whatever
and you're wanting your app and the
next day you're back in there
again and it's, you're sure know,
you sure it's sore,
but you don't know what it is and you
just average after awhile I didn't know
you store your Achilles
tendon. I did that. I didn't
care my tendon. Oh, good ACL.
Why'd you say I told my tendon or the
sick for whatever reason. You said ACL?
Yeah. Achilles tendon. No, no, no,
no. That sucks. But the Achilles,
now one of the girls
that works with Heather,
she had it done and they fixed it so fast.
They reattach it to the
bone now and you're walking
around like immediately real.
It's fucking crazy. That's not the
way it was when it's like six months.
Let's more thing. Right. Horrible this
year. But that no one else is crazy now.
BICEP tendon tears. Jeff
Dubitsky, the u s you Usada Guy,
he had his bicep tendon torn.
They replaced that shit.
They did bolted that shit down to the
arm and he was moving around like normal
within a couple of days.
Wow.
It's like he doesn't have
any strengthening while the
rebuild his strength back,
but it used to be you are in a fucking
cast and you couldn't do shit and it took
forever to rehab and it was awesome.
Now it's like they just bolt things down.
There's, there's new techniques now
where they can um, Doctor Rati Mcgann,
a Vegas was explained to me
when you tear an ACL in half,
instead of replacing the ACL,
now they put that ACL back together again.
They have new techniques of tying
the ACL back together, going to,
it heals up fully and they've had guys
go back into the Olympics within four
months of this surgery. Like
what in the fuck. Exactly.
This,
we're going to crazy time when it comes
to regeneration and the ability to fix
things,
repair things.
They're constantly innovating and
coming up with new surgical procedures.
So awesome time to get fucked up. Oh
yeah. I've done a great job of that.
You know that my thing, I
got to the point, it it,
it actually atrophied me so
bad. Yeah. I mean, I was like,
and my wife would look, she'd go
every day she goes, oh my God.
You know my shoulders like I had,
they were concave in the
back where you are a giant.
When I met you when I first met you,
you had been doing a lot of
power lifting and you were three.
What will you three how much
you weigh? Three. 10, three
10. You were fucking huge.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Not
Anymore. Do you roll anymore?
I have not rolled since July. Since
that injury and said I'm done. No,
my wife, she's hearing she's in the other
room. She's going to knock on the door.
You're done. Motherfucker was, she'll
say, you can roll with the black belt. Oh,
okay. She doesn't want me
rolling with people that go
spastic. Right, right, right.
That makes sense. Yeah. Do you, so
you're able to work out though slow.
It was a point I, I'd have to
pick up my arm to put it up here.
Pat Miletich was here. Oh, same thing.
And Pass Rutan Pat has his
discs fused on their own.
That's where minded around
the, uh, around the cage bone.
Pat didn't even do it around a cage paths.
Neck was so fucked up.
There was no disc left at the
bones just grew into each other.
I remember when pat had, he fought
you remember back a long time ago.
Jose Paly Landy. John's. Oh yeah. And he,
he had to stop in the fight because
Jose was grabbing a hold of a Moyie Thai
plum and it was killing Pat's neck
because his neck was just jacked and he
couldn't finally gets to the point.
He was like, I can't do it anymore.
And it was all based on
injuries. Yeah. Yeah.
He wasn't getting beaten the fight by
what was happening by the fighter hurting
him.
It was just someone hanging on his neck.
Cause all I know a lot of guys have
gotten the neck really fucked up from can
openers, tell me about it.
It can offer. It's just that,
that technique of opening up the guard.
Well Tim could Tafoya was the
one that really started Oh yeah.
Out The can opener. And it was Mark
Kerr and Mark Coleman. Oh yeah.
That guy was a fucking gorilla.
A big old gray haired gray haired girl.
He looked like a silver badge.
They gray. Oh yeah. So he like,
he had great chest hairs and a crazy gray
mustache and built like a fucking tank.
He was just yanking on things. He
wasn't taking anything. Yeah. Yeah.
He was yanking on shit. But Coleman
and incur that was there. Yup. Call.
I remember curt fuck somebody up in pride.
Some a Russian cat. Oh wait a minute.
Can Open and fucked his neck up. And
when that was Bronco? Yes, that's right.
Was it him? Yeah. Well that was the first
one that he did. And then he had, um,
he was a Russian guy. Trying to think
of who that, I forget the guy's name,
but I remember the guys writhing in
agony holding onto his neck and I'm,
I'm thinking fuck that. And that
was the smashing machine, Kurt,
that was car when he was on
all the Mexican supplements.
He was on everything they ever
invented in labs. Whose job? Well,
I can tell you about it now. I
rolled with it. I was rolling with,
why would you roll with Kirk?
Did you roll with, I did not.
I never rode with marker, but I
rolled with Mark Coleman. Ah, Jesus,
that's not better Kevin.
Randleman oh my God.
It was funny though, cause with
first we were trying to, Oh hey,
we'll just roll in the on. Right. And
then it was willing to, you know, hey,
I've been working on this
defense that's not going to work.
And he actually told me,
Pat Pat took,
pat military told me that he didn't teach
it that way. Dude, I'm just telling you,
you know,
and it was triangle defense.
He cause he's fighting in pride and
he's getting triangled by Totoro.
But he would sit there and he put
his hand to his forehead. Oh, Jesus.
But he was the strongest human
being I had ever rolled with.
He changed a lot of people's games.
People don't realize.
Like when Mark Coleman came into the game,
like with Mark Coleman beat Dan Severen,
um,
and just got him in that scarf
hold and cranked on his neck.
When people saw what mark was doing to
people, everybody got bigger. Everybody.
That was when [inaudible]
went up to like two 40.
Oh that everybody got bigger because they
were just saying in one day I'm going
to have to fight that fucking
gorilla. Like I got to get that. Gee,
I just got to get at least 40
pounds bigger. I love mark.
At a certain point he hated
me because, you know, look,
I changed the rules on him.
It was me, the headbutts cause
you, you change the headbutts.
See I like head butts. I think there are
four lie for him. They were very fast.
Oh my God. He would, he would take
you down. Guys would grab over,
hook his arms and he would just,
he would use that big old
Mellon to just wish him.
But the crazy thing is when Maury Smith
beat Mark Hollmann headbutts were legal.
Yes they were.
They were legal
back then. Our last one. Still
one. That was the last last show.
That's why I'm in favor of headbutts.
It's like there's a defense for them.
You can do it. You can figure it out
and Maurice figured it out, but it's,
it's perception and that's what the
entire sport has fought for its entire
existence. Well, let me tell you this
because I'm beating a dead horse in this.
Everybody listens to this podcast
knows I don't like gloves.
I don't think guys should have to
wear gloves because I don't think.
Tell me why you don't like
clubs because I think,
why should you have padding on your
knuckles that makes your knuckles more
effective when you don't have it on your
shins? You don't have it on your elbows.
You don't have it on your knees. Right?
It doesn't make any sense. Your heel,
your heel is one of the hardest
parts of your fucking body.
You mean everybody's seen Edson Barboza,
Terry, Adam. Fuck that perception.
How is it okay to Shin somebody in
the head? This is the perception.
It's the reality informed
back. Okay, let's go back.
We're going back all the way to UFC.
The way back machine.
UFC eight was the first time that
I ended up in court before UFCA.
Okay. Because John Mccain had come out
with this whole thing and everyone can sit
there and say why John did it. No
Budweiser. Oh my, thank you very much.
You hit it right on the wiser
was sponsoring boxing mango.
I hear all the stories. We'll all
know John Mccain did us a favor will.
You weren't there at that time.
He didn't do us any. Damn.
They brought him in because they knew
that they needed someone who is very
respected to be against MMA. Exactly. You
gotta got to look at the paper reviews.
The very first paper view
for the UFC 87,000 buys.
They were hoping for a home run it around
25 they got 87002nd one they were in
the 200 180 some thousand then
200,300 put into perspective today.
Sometimes I think w w who is the,
there was a fight on mighty mouse.
There was a fight fairly recently where
mighty mouse paper view where I think it
only got 150 you know, let's be
honest. I think probably the, the,
the last one they had,
it's not going to be up there because
there was so much Amanda Nunez. Yeah.
Well there's so much
competition around it,
but you had a Llama Chanko fighting the
same night for free. Right. You know,
and so people look and go, ah, you know,
on this one I can still watch something.
And it's not that that wasn't a good card,
it's just the matter of was it the same
night as Bell Tower was built on Friday,
you had all those things and only one
of them you had to pay for. Yeah. Right,
exactly. But you look at all
of that man, and it's like,
it's crazy. Yeah. Crazy. What happened?
Because John Mccain comes out,
we go to court in,
because Puerto Rico, he sends a letter
there and they tried to shut it down.
We ended up in federal court and they
bring in this boxing expert to be on their
side. And one of the things I did is they
had gloves and they're talking about,
we had no gloves. And I said, you know,
and I took the glove and I said, here,
I want to do a demonstration for
you for the, for the judge. I said,
I would like that boxing expert.
Take your hand,
put it in that glove and I want you
to hit this desk. Hit it hard, hit it
as hard as you can. And he goes, crack,
take it off. Hit it just as hard now.
And he goes, well, I
said, this is my point.
That glove is not there
to protect my head.
It is there to protect his hand.
That is what a glove is for.
A glove does not protect someone as far
as their brain's scrambling or anything.
It is there to protect my
hands so I can punch you more.
That's what it's there for
a hundred percent okay.
And if you look and say if you want to
take away some things that go with what's
the most traumatic
injuries we have in MMA,
people are going to look and say
all this stuff about, oh we have,
you know guys breaking on.
Concussions are the most important
thing that we have going on.
That's the most critical
thing we have going on.
And if someone gets to punch less
because they have to be more precise with
where they're doing it and be careful
as far as how many times they do do it
because they can't continue to do it.
You know, in that prolonged fashion.
Does it make it safer or is it
more dangerous for the fighters?
But it's a perception and it's,
you know,
this goes back to athletic commissions
and everything. It's crazy.
Has An MMA and UFC
transcendent assumption,
which I wish in a certain extent.
Are you kidding me?
You're still talking about
an elbow strike thing.
Let's go back to that cause people
don't, we never, we glossed over it.
I did a great segway.
There is the first time I've ever done
anyone segue to 12 six elbow strike.
Was it because this is what I've always
said and I believe you're the one who
told me this, that when the commissions
were talking about techniques,
they had seen like those karate guys
and ESPN at one o'clock in the morning
breaking bricks with their
elbows and they like you.
Just no way you could allow that
strike because that's dry call.
It would be two deadly was that
what happened? Close, close.
When we talk about commissions,
there was only a couple of commissions
at the writing of the unified rules as
far as when we came, you
know, to get a degree.
That was back in April of 2001 all right.
And New Jersey and we started talking
about the UFC was not the first, you know,
showing show to go there,
but New Jersey after they had the IFC
and then the UFC and then they had a
couple of other small shows,
ring of fire starts to come in
and everyone has their own rules.
The UFC had their own rules.
IFC had their own rules during a fire,
wants to do their own rules and New
Jersey was that we can't have these people
coming in and giving us what
their rules are. We, if,
if we're going to do this as a sport,
we're going to do this
under our rules and okay,
what we're going to do is we're going
to bring people together to create those
rules. The people that are
supposedly know what the,
who they really invited other than,
you know,
I think you had the Mohegan Sun as far
as the tribal commission come down and
they were part of it.
New Jersey has a commission and you
had mark Ratner on a conference call.
He was not there,
but it was promoted for Ratner work for
the UFC as long before because working
for the Nevada,
Nevada state athletic commission,
he's the executive director and they
bring in all of these promoters and the
promoters were king of the cage. Terry
trouble cock. You had Dana White,
Lorenzo Fertitta, John McCarthy, Joe
Silva and Jeff Blatnick from the UFC.
You had people from pride,
Yuki Kondo and uh,
Kinda or whatever. And, uh, had
decade, I can't remember his name.
And you had Paul Smith, you
had a couple, but that was it.
That was the people there.
And the people that we're really talking
the most were was me and a doctor named
Dom Coletta from New Jersey.
He was brought in as the medical
advisor for the state of New Jersey.
And when it came to elbows, they,
they, they tried to get rid of elbows.
That was their big thing.
And I was,
I was sitting there trying to combat
what they were saying because even in New
Jersey at the time they had Muay Thai
and so they had elbows that were allowed
in this form. I said, look it and,
and Jeff and I had put
together a CD at the time,
you know you had cds with CD Rom.
Yeah, there you go man. And uh, it was,
cause I knew they were going to attack
throws because that was what made Larry
Hazard.
You had Tito Ortiz fought Evan Tanner
and he picks him up in a body lock and he
brings him down and he knocks him out.
And Larry Hazard when his heart started
going, he's like, oh, we don't like that.
And so I knew they were
going to attack throws and,
and so I took with Jeff put together all
of these throws from the 1996 Olympics
in Atlanta.
Here's all your throws from judo,
here's all your throws from Greco Roman.
Right?
And God blessed Carolyn because he picks
people up and drop them on their head
and it's legal. Okay. And I had all
these throws from freestyle wrestling,
Greco Roman wrestling,
judo with all of these Olympic athletes
picking somebody up and then falling on
their head being tossed on their head.
And that's what saved the throws.
And what we came up with was,
look,
what we don't want is someone being
able to control another human being and
purposely make a 10th spike out of them
and try to drive them down onto the mat
on top of their heads while driver.
Exactly.
So Bob Sapp did two minute Tara in pride,
pride in different set of rules
for a long time. And that's,
you know, maybe forever. That
was what we were looking at.
And so that's how we came up with,
you know, no spiking and spiking.
I knew what it was because I worked out
the language there cause I was sitting
there saying well hold
on, time out. You want it.
I'm the one that's got to come up
and say this is legal, this is not.
So we do this. If someone takes an,
you know, a guy shoots a lazy double,
he brings his head to the center,
picks him up,
his legs need to go
straight up or you know,
his legs were out like this
and you purposely holding
there and try to drive him
straight down. That's a
spike. That's illegal.
If I take and I pick you up as a
suplex and I bring you up over the top,
I can bring you down any as
long as there is an arc to it.
Any arc makes the throw legal.
So rampage Jackson picks up Ryan Bader
and spins him and brings him down
straight on his head. Legal and it makes
it quick and easy for me as a referee.
I see the arc, it's
legal. I don't see an arc.
And I see him holding them
and bring them straight down.
Now I know it's illegal and so I was
trying to make things as easy as I could
when it came to the elbows,
what they were trying to do was take
away all elbows and I go, look at,
you have elbows in Muay Thai elbows.
Every time you take something away you
are changing the sport and making it to
where it's harder to actually have
action because you take away elbows.
I grab her wrist and if
I'm good at grabbing wrist,
I can hold risk for a while
and I can't do anything.
I've got to pull my hand out where if you
grabbed my wrist and I'm Jon Jones and
I take an eye, roll that elbow
over and boom and bring it down.
You let go of my risks
because you're being attacked.
And so they looked at it and said,
and the Tom Coletta being the doctor said,
he goes, look it. Yeah, I understand
what he's saying. And he said,
I have a problem with one.
And it came from Gannon McGee
versus a guy named Brad Gabe.
A Bad Brad Gabriel from the IFC,
the very first show,
they had gan mugging, you know,
you remember six foot 11 you know,
at the time in this show,
about 335 pounds.
And he's fighting a guy named Brad Gabriel
who is 61 200 ten two hundred fifteen
pounds.
And Gavin Your Brat,
Gabriel is trying to get a hold again just
to survive and Ganis taken his armies,
boom, boom, boom.
And he's bringing it straight down
on top of Brad Gabriel's head.
And then he gets his back
and he does the same thing,
like the old Brazilian style of
boom shots to the back of the head.
And he said, he goes, I, I've seen,
I can't have that. He's, I see,
I've seen them break big blocks of ice
like that. That's a dangerous hell,
but we can't have that.
And I started to combat it and Lorenzo
Fertitta looks at me, he goes, John,
let it go. It's stupid.
And I go, yes sir, boss.
And I backed away from it. And so
that became, so that's the 12 to six,
that's the 12 to six elbow.
And the whole thing with
the whole positioning of it.
12 to six I came up with that.
They're saying, all right,
let me just make this clear that,
so we're saying that my hand comes
straight up and straight down.
That's what's illegal.
So 12 o'clock to six o'clock but if I'm
inside control and I bring my arm like
this, we're okay with it. And they
go yes. And one to seven, okay.
One to seven 1132 all that stuff
sort of 1130 is pushing it.
You're pushing it. But, and the,
the problem was, see I was there,
I understood everything and I came out
and started teaching classes and stuff
and it, if you listened to me, you
knew what it was. But other than that,
you're getting, oh,
there's a paper written.
So you're reading the paper and
it says no downward elbow strikes.
And that's not what the rule was.
Right. So we had actually had, you know,
season two of the ultimate fighter.
Joe Stevenson is going to end up,
he's in the semifinals. I had done
his earlier match. He had fought, uh,
Marcus Davis and I'd went
over the rules with him.
And so when we talk about
going over rules with fighters,
there's a lot that I say, you
know, people think that, you
know, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Don't Topo hair don't
do that. You don't do that.
But I had gone over things and explained
to him, yes, he, he, cause he asked me,
he says, in the guard, can I do this
album? Absolutely. From the guard.
You can do it from the cause.
You're doing it from six to 20.
Exactly what you're doing it. It's
nine to three, three to nine, whatever.
You're on your back. Right. And he goes,
and he's going to fight in the semifinals
and he's got herb dean is as referee.
And herb tells them, no, you
can't do that. And he goes,
but John McCarthy says I can do it.
And he goes, no, you can't do that.
And so I got one. This is the
problem with MMA as we have it.
Herb says, no. Joe Comes
out to me and says, Hey,
you told me that I could do
this. I said, absolutely you can.
He goes to her dean just said, I
can't. I go, I'll take care of it,
and I go to her and I said,
hey,
did you tell Joe Stevenson that he can't
do this elbow strike? He goes, yeah.
He goes, that's illegal. You can't do
that. I go, Joe. I said, herb, I go,
what do you mean it's illegal?
I go, it's 12 to six. I go,
his hands not coming straight
up and straight down, and
he goes, yeah. Johnny goes,
that's if the clocks on the wall,
but if you're on your back and your
clocks on the ceiling, he goes,
that's 12 to six oh Jesus.
Oh, this is what happens. And
I, I looked at and I said,
what in the fuck? Have you ever seen
a clock on a ceiling? And he goes,
what happened?
But it makes sense and you have
these official enhanced by gravity.
Hello, but it's still, it's gravity.
It doesn't make any sense right now.
I can tell you changed because of doctors
and fear that no one wants to be the
one to change it. Look at, look at all
the controversy we had when we changed.
Just the little bit that
we've changed so far.
And that was one of the things we wanted
to change the hand touch. We had it.
Yeah,
and I'll talk about that if you want.
But we had it in there and the
doctors for the ABC said, Nope,
we don't want to touch that.
So right now I can tell you what was
their rationale, their rationales,
they don't understand it and
they're afraid to say they are.
They look at the sport and they look at
it from a different view than you and I
as people that are a part of it.
You and I as fans, any of that,
they look at it from,
well right now we've been doing
this for we'll say 20 years,
15 years, wherever you're at,
how long they've been doing it.
And we haven't had a problem
having that as being illegal.
So as soon as we bring it into,
okay,
now it's legal and we have a fighter
that supposedly gets hurt by it and now
they come after us saying, well, before
it was illegal, you guys made it legal.
That's why I got hurt. And that's what
they're trying to avoid. They don't,
they're looking at litigation and
they're looking at saying, you know what?
Why bring that in? There's no
point. It's so frustrating.
Totally. That's a very frustrated
right now, I will tell you,
the University of Auburn is doing a
study for us about elbows and the power
behind each different type
that we were having them do,
being that one up and down.
So I've already had,
I used to do things with sports science
and they've already done that test for
me,
so I know what it is.
But we'll have a university having a
test and so now it's going to come out.
That elbow strikes it.
All these elbow strikes that are allowed
are all much more powerful than that
elbow strike. And not only that, but
forget about power because you know,
you could take whatever Dominick Cruz
is most powerful technique and then use
Francis and Ganos Jack.
So are we,
are we just saying that you can't have
power because that doesn't make any sense
at all. Well, no,
because see that's what the whole
thing is with that elbow strike. Right?
It's so powerful.
But what about a fucking,
it's not exactly nothing compared
to like a wheel spinning back kick.
I tried to get people to understand,
you know, you being a hunter,
you have an idea of ballistics.
Okay.
And it's like people get in this
whole thing about, you know,
girls and guys and fighting and
stuff. And I try to tell him, look it,
you cannot expect Demetrius Johnson to
have the power of a Francis and in Ghana
or Steve, no chick or stupid
music or Daniel Cormay or
let's go down, Lord George,
Saint Pierre, giant
heavy. He has 125 pounds.
We'll say the ninth of east fighting
130 539 pounds of weight behind it.
He is a 22 caliber. Right? Okay.
I'm not saying he can't hurt you,
but he's not going to drop you because
he just doesn't have that size and you
have certain genetics.
It's not genetics.
Certain components that are coming into
play because like the Joseph Benevidez
fight with Joseph Joseph
was doing forward,
him brings it coming in more power
based upon movement of bodies.
He can drop some decision timing.
He can drop somebody with a kick because
there's more weight and power behind it.
He can drop somebody with a knee. But
when we look at lighter weight fighters,
we're going to get people, human beings
are put together basically the same. Okay.
Obviously there's this guy can
take a shot. This guy can't, okay,
that's out there.
But if you're a fighter and you
get used to accepting damage,
accepting punishment,
you can accept a lot of
things to a certain point
where that person's speed and
power come together to create a
velocity that will put anybody out.
And that just comes with
strength and weight and size.
Because the 22 caliber bullet is not
like the 45 caliber bullet and no matter
who the athlete is,
the downward elbow is not going to be
the most powerful strike and there are
snow unless they're just some
fucking downward elbow wizard.
And there might be filling those guys out
there. I mean it's, and the tie world,
there might be some guy who does one of
those Tomahawk elbows that just has a
vicious one. But for those guys,
for this few and far between,
so tell me how that elbow is going to
be stronger than a guy with the rolling
thunder kick with his heel hitting
someone in the top. It's not going to be,
or it's in Barboza wheel
kick. Hello. There's,
there's power that you just
can't eat from leg kicks,
especially from kicks with the leg.
Rather you just,
there's no way you're going to be able
to match that with anything you do with
your arms. Never, never, never, never.
But yet those are legal techniques because
they did legal forever and they just
don't want to take any chances.
There's a comfort level with it and
we've allowed that for this long.
That's normal.
You know what you're getting into.
And now I start to change it and look
at, there will be, I hate to say this,
there will be one fighter out there,
whoever they are, who ends up saying,
well I'm going to,
I have this lawyer who said I could make
money and they're going to sue somebody
over it, you know, and they're gonna say,
that's what that was what got me hurt. Mm.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's why you'll never see like knees
to the head on the r eight happened.
Just telling you right now, not
going to ever. Never, never, never.
As soon as one person gets it is
to the technique. Super valid.
And you cannot put yourself
into positions. And this is,
fighters are always going to work
within the parameters of what they have,
right? And they're going to work
to, how can I benefit from this?
What can I do to make this work for
me? I don't care what it is, you know,
be it the cage, the ring,
you know the technique.
There are always going to work at making
that thing work for them to the best
that they can.
That's their job and I don't blame them.
That's the way it's supposed to be.
I'm going to beat it out of the dead
horse because this is something I talk
about all the time.
What do you think about having fights
in an open area like a basketball court
and not having a cage? Because
I feel like the cage, there's,
there's certain things about the cage
there is it becomes an added factor.
Does it ring become an added factor?
Yes.
And so what a basketball
court to a certain extent.
To a complete extent because
batteries are not stupid, right?
There's smart and be able to use it,
get back up and you wouldn't be able to
use it to hold a guy that you would be
able to use it to nullify.
Same as in wrestling.
Ligo there just run out
of bounds the exactly.
And Trust me guys would start doing it
to keep themselves safe because football
field, you know, take, take a think
about it. Think about when you, well,
think about when you
first were at the UFC,
UFC 12 back then if Mark
Coleman took somebody down,
where did he put them? Right against
Kate. Head up against the cage.
People didn't wall walk then did. Nope,
they didn't know it. Yeah, exactly.
And they get their brains beaten in.
Exactly.
And then the cage was a benefit
for the guy on top. Exactly. Yeah.
But still it's about reverse to a certain
oh most. But then people were like,
oh, but takedowns against the cage take
downs are a bitch against the cage.
They are,
but so stop trying to do that.
It's also possible to get that
clinch when you're pressing up a guy,
get the hands together behind the legs
and you could look at the difference in
the cages because I'm going to tell you
right now, there's differences in you.
Trying to say the bell to cage
is better than UFC kitchen.
I'll shut these goddamn
microphones off right now. No,
but there is a difference in those
cages in that the USC has what we call a
canvas.
That is an infinity line canvas.
The fencing material is around it
and there's an actual gap that,
so if you spill ice in the UFC cage, no
problem. You just sweep it into that hole.
Some guys who've got their foot stuck
in that hole before I absolutely,
but they purposely many times put their
foot there to, to brace against the tape.
Two key because it's now it becomes,
instead of me having to pull
and have to having to lift,
we'll say 80 pounds of pressure, that
pressure becomes 160 pounds of pressure,
whereas it's doubled edged in
there. Then go. Yeah. You know,
and so as a fuck their ankle up on
that thank guys reflect their toes up.
They've done a lot of things,
but they utilize whatever they have.
But don't you think just for the purity
of the sport of football field be a
better way to go?
I think you make the guys fighting the
metal and then you'd have guys running
and people would be going,
what?
I know that fucking guy always
uses the warning zone. Exactly.
He's going to the answer and I hated
that guy and there's no perfect.
There's no perfect. What about,
um, the way, uh, when Myra,
what's came back, remember he
had that Yama pit? Oh yeah.
Remember that I went guys have tried that
sort of strategy is having a pit type
scenario. Frank shamrock was
the first one. In fact I was,
I was arguing with Josh Thomson about
it. It was called shoe box. Shoe box.
That's right.
It was first called Boo Szeto and it
got shut down by Pry Bushido it was like
pride Machito as far as you know,
same name,
but it got shut down and then when he
reopened it up it was shoot box cause it
never really happened. It was grappling
thing. So it was like a copyright thing.
And so he went with shoe
box and it did have that,
it was a school more of a
square with the raised sides.
Anyone you can go to the, you know,
go to Chuck Norris is and you know,
World Combat League member,
the member, the surface shore.
And it was great to watch.
And it's for the fans as far as viewing,
it's the best they do. Doing a karate
thing now. Bas Rutten's doing commentary,
same Serrati comp combat karate,
sorry. Same sort of deal. Yeah,
it's doing and it's a little bit higher
around the sides on the rap. I like that.
Yeah. But trust me, guys are gonna
use it. They're gonna use, you know,
back back when Bob Myerwitz
tried to come back with Yama,
he asked me to be part of that and I
said no, I'm sorry I can't, you know.
And it wasn't, I was trying
to be an idiot. I just, and
I told him, I said, look it,
I said, your your little, cause he was
saying this is going revolution. I said,
no it's not. I go to, I said that
ramp is going to make my, he goes,
it's [inaudible]. He thought it was
going to work against takedowns.
I said it's going make takedowns
easier cause if I back you towards it,
now I elevate you. That just
changes my ability to drop levels.
Here's the karate ramp coin logo in the
center of college. Boy. There you go.
Like that. I like this, but it gets
great. If you get stuck up
against that side, you're,
you can't back your foot up any further.
We'll make take down, see, but easier.
But then now you get into, let's talk
about reality. Okay. You look at that.
That looks great. It's so great.
It's in a TV studio, right?
Because let's put that in an arena now
because every, all of those big money,
ringside seats, it can't
see shit. Bingo. Right.
Especially if you're up against the edge.
Yeah,
but that's a problem right now in MMA,
if you watch a fight and you're,
yeah, I get sometimes. I see sometimes
you've got the greatest team,
the greatest Seton,
how it next to you and when the,
when the posts are in the position.
So you went from the greatest seat in
the house, the second grade a seat.
Now you also went from the hardest job
in the business too. In my opinion.
The easiest. No, not at all. Commentaries
the easiest. No, I want to look at it.
You have set a standard for commentators
and, and, and the real thing is, you know,
people talk all,
you're always gonna have people that
love you and people that hate you.
And that's just people.
But you set a standard for the way that
you call a fight with the enthusiasm
that you truly have for the sport.
That always made you phenomenal at
what you did. It's not only the,
the knowledge that you had about fighting,
it was the way you went about presenting
our sport and you made it happen.
And you know,
you're part of the whole thing of why
the sport has gotten as big as it is.
And I appreciate that. It's very
nice, very nice of you. It's easy.
It's not an easy job. It's that easy
man to show up and start yelling.
Well, for me, what is easy about it is
that it's natural is that, uh, you know,
I don't like sports.
I'm not a sports guy.
People come to me and they start
talking to me about football.
I literally don't have any idea what
they're talking about when I watch a
football game. I don't know what's
happening. This the flag gets,
what's the flag for what
happened? Penalty. What's
going on? Basketball Games.
I know that when the ball goes in the
hole with the rope around it, that's good.
It's all I know. Soccer have no fucking
idea what's going on. It looks great.
They're running around.
But I know fighting and I am
enthusiastic about fighting and to me,
I don't have any room for
any other shit in my head.
So when I call fights,
I mean that, look man,
I watched every fight this past weekend.
I watched the Loma Chanko fight.
I watched Beltre fine. I was there
all great. Ryan Bader, King Mo.
I watched the UFC fight. Amanda Nunez,
Raquel Pennington. I watched everything.
I will love watching combat sports
is my favorite thing to watch.
Know that we were talking
earlier and it's like, you know,
as a fan I would love to have,
I ain't even boxers everybody in one
little gut. This is the group that,
this is what we watched for fighting
cause I get to see the best against the
best. Yeah. As a fighter, it's horrible.
You've got to have competition out there.
You've got to have more promotions
because the fighter has nothing going for
them. If there's not other
places they can be, you know,
and boxing his has changed.
You know I still do boxing
and boxing has changed
as far as it used to be so hard to get
Lenora's against Loma Chanko because Leon
Aras is this champion in Loma
Chicos a champion in this way class.
And so we're going to talk about this
forever because we're going to build this
up, build this up to the point where
it becomes Pacquiao, Mayweather and it,
you lost it years ago.
And with MMA people look and they go,
I wish there could be cross
promotions and look at there.
There are the only one that doesn't
is the UFC. Okay and, and you can't,
you have to understand that.
First off, Dana did do that.
He did it with pride and he got screwed.
They tried it with member when Vandelay
came over and they made this little van,
I didn't come over. They fighting
chuck and Dave put them in the cage.
They put soccer Robin in the cage.
All it did was promote pride. Exactly.
Because Dana gave, chuck took pride,
he gave Rico Rodriguez to pride.
He gave them fighters, right.
That went over there and fought.
Especially chuck when Chuck was
really a very big part of the UFC.
She just wasn't the champion.
He was number one, you know,
and he got screwed by it and he was like,
okay,
that ain't gonna ever happen again. And
so you can't blame him. I look and go,
I understand why you say screw
that. And it can, you know,
in some ways I guess it
can diminish your product.
If someone comes from the outside and
you know it goes against your champion,
it could diminish your product
if you want to say that.
I don't think it does look at,
it's a matter of people watch fighting,
not for promotions. They watch
fighting for fighting. It's,
that's why lead versus athlete.
That's why it's weird.
That's why this UFC thing or Bella tour
thing is weird because nobody gives a
fuck who Gennady Golovkin fights for.
They don't give a shit.
If it's on HBO or if it's on showtime,
it's like triple g's fight tonight. How
do I watch how I watch it? You know?
But that's the difference between what
happened with MMA. Right. I can tell you,
you know,
back before UFC,
UFC 30 was the first one that the
Fertittas were the owners of the UFC.
And I can remember going to,
was it the market is arena at the Trump
Taj Mahal and you know they're doing
Tito's walkout cause
Tito was the champion.
He's going to fight Evan Tanner and it's,
they're doing this,
they had to actually do this firework
display and they had to do it before the
show. So the fire marshal would approve
it. So you had to pay for it twice,
you know, and it was like $50,000
worth of fireworks. Right.
And so it was this whole
thing and he says, Hey,
do you want to watch it and you know
normal. I said, yeah, absolutely.
And we're standing there
talking and Lorenzo at that
time told me, he says, man,
I want to be the first promoter to be
able to pay an MMA fighter $1 million for
a fight. And I told him, that's awesome.
He goes, he says, he goes, and he goes,
we're going to build this up.
And he's talking to me and when he was
talking about, I said, you know Lorenzo,
the only thing I can tell
you is, hey, that everything
you're saying is fantastic,
I love it,
but there's only one thing you can
control and that's your promotion.
You have the UFC, because he was
talking about Bob [inaudible],
it's not pushing fighters.
He was pushing the UFC more and I said,
there'll get a point where you think you
have that fight or you have them under
contract and now you want them to do this,
you're going to set them up for this.
And he's like, no, I don't
want to do that. I think I'd
rather just do this. I said,
you're always going to have
issues with fighters to a point.
It's just they're looking
at what's best for them.
And you're looking at what's best for you.
And there's got to be always that
compromise towards the middle.
I go so you can always control the brand.
And eventually that's what he realized
his and he pushed and he made the UFC the
brand cause it was pride UFC.
And he started,
you know,
from the ultimate fighter.
He started having this term where people
associated the UFC with mixed martial
arts. They didn't say mixed martial
arts. They said, oh the UFC,
it's like Kleenex or xerox.
And he did an unbelievable job with that.
That's what his job was, is to build
his company. He did, he sold it.
And he's a smart man.
They definitely didn't nail it.
There's no doubt about Lilly.
Obviously I'm a giant fan of
the UFC and very low them. But,
but I want to see Rory Macdonald
fight the best fighters in the world.
And I think that Roy McDonald is
one of the best, if not the best,
170 pound fighter on the planet.
There's no doubt. There's no doubt.
I mean you watch his fight
with Tyron Woodley and I
understand. I did that fight.
It was a long time ago and
Woodley's a different fighter now,
especially under the tutelage
of Duke Roufus. He's just,
but he's a better fighter. Roy Shut
them down. I mean, took away everything.
It took away everything he did and
he showed this very, very deep,
well rounded game.
Look at
there's,
and this is what this is.
Another thing that people don't get is
the UFC has a huge stable of fighters and
I will tell you, look, you can,
how many fighters?
His belt or having a contract,
probably about 200 to 220 UFC
is going to be about 600 yeah,
it's quite a bit more. Yeah, and
it's, in terms of world class,
there's no competition. There's many,
many more world class fighters in the UFC.
But you got Michael Chandler,
you got,
you got some serious fighters
over in, in Beltour. Look at you.
You take a look at the hunter
and seventies you know who
Ed Ruth is? Sure. Okay.
Yeah. Add Ruth's going to be a monster, a
monster, a monster. Aaron Peko. Eric. Oh,
how about that left hook again?
That's under left.
Took second one of the body kids only had
two fights, you know, three fights now.
And I'm telling you right
now they're talking in fact,
cause he works out with Freddie Roach.
I was with Freddy the other day cause
they brought back the contender number,
the contender that was from boxing.
They're bringing it back and so I'm,
I'm doing stuff there. And when
is Pecos third fight? His, his.
He just had his fourth fight.
He just had his fourth. Yup.
Why did I think he only had three? He
did until Saturday night. Oh that he,
that's right. Once finally
Morrison. That's right. Yeah.
And it took them to the body. Yup. Yeah,
it's left. Took his nasty, you know,
Freddie Roach will tell you
John, you know, he'll tell
you Joe, he's the real deal.
Oh, he's definitely going to be
a champion in boxing. He goes,
and I'm not kidding you,
the kid was Miguel Cotto sparring
partner for Miguel's entire camp. Okay.
He goes, I wouldn't put anybody in.
That's not going to be perfect for Miguel.
That can actually stay with Miguel.
Maybe not hurt Miguel,
but I wouldn't put anybody in there
that wasn't a high level. He goes,
I used them the entire camp.
Yeah, he's a super athlete. Scary,
scary, good. And what
2021 now. 21 yup. Yeah.
I mean he hasn't even started scratching
his prime. Not even in the neighborhood.
And he's just a freak as far look at,
this is what he does and he gets it. He's,
he's Kinda like the Floyd and you know,
he gets up at two o'clock in the morning,
starts running or working out, you know,
he jumps up out of bed and does, you know,
a hundred pushups. You go do go to
sleep, but it's a drive. You know,
you want to feed the drive as much as
you want to feed the body. And that's,
you know,
when you're looking at fighters,
it's that drive to get to somewhere and
then the ability to hold on to that.
Once you've reached that pinnacle,
now it's the drive to,
to get excited and to do things here.
There it is right there.
You got to get away.
Just a little bit all the way back.
It's just highlights.
Bring it back to the beginning so you
can see that it is, oh, he throws it,
he doesn't throw wide either.
He throws it up the middle like right,
right to the rib area right next to the
solar plexus. You gotta stop doing that.
Whatever iron fisted
matador means matador.
Let that go. I have kids that kill
her though. No doubt about it.
I mean, look, Beltour also has Bella tour
kickboxing, which I'm a great admirer.
I love that they're doing that high level
and that's obviously Scott's original
background. You know, I love the fact
that doing high level kickboxing too,
and you know John Wayne par and Joe over
there and Ray Daniels Petrosian Georgia
petrosal was he something to watch?
See, that's what I like when I'm,
when I'm refereeing him, I go,
thank God I never had to fight you.
He's such a master.
Oh,
Petrosian is doing just some really
special things in there when you watch his
movement and this sub, some great
breakdowns of his technique online.
But if you watch is just footwork and
angles and he's just never there for you.
You know what I mean?
He's just,
he's one of the masteries the
Loma Chenko of kickboxing. Yeah.
He's one of the masters. Yeah. But I mean,
I've always made the argument that I,
I love kickboxing, but I really would
appreciate more tie better. I liked,
I liked the elbows. I like the knees. If
you're gonna, if you're just striking,
she'd be able to do everything, be able to
clench. And this is the, in my personal,
and I could be wrong,
but this is the problem that we
have with kickboxing and Muay Thai.
Both is people don't know
what they're watching. Right.
And then when they don't understand it,
same as you said,
I don't understand football.
I don't understand soccer.
As soon as you don't understand what
you're watching, you start to get, Eh,
I could not not do it.
It's understanding this is what's
allowed and being part of it now you're
invested in it. But if you don't
understand what the rule sets are,
and there's so many rules sets when
it comes to kickboxing, they've,
they've got to come together
and come up with one another.
And if it's the Muay Thai set,
fine,
get rid of the music because the
music doesn't work here in the,
in North America. Now the
music and also the, you know,
the why crew in the beginning around,
no, no one's going to get into that.
It's just not gonna fly in
America. Nope. I mean there's some,
I don't think it's a bad idea to make
some changes for the American audience.
Some you've got one and that's,
that's where you get the pushback
and the resistance is, hey,
this is part of our tradition and I,
I totally understand that.
I'm not against it, but do you
want this to work or do you not?
Because that's what it's come down
to. The tradition I get, I mean,
I do get it and I appreciate it and
it's nice and everything like that,
but people aren't going to sit
around for that. There's not, nope,
we don't have time. And
everyone's on Adderall. That's
going to want to go, go, go,
go, go, go, go. They don't want
to sit around for that, you know?
Where do you think MMA is
headed? When you, when you,
you look at the sport and you,
do you have a sense, I mean you,
you've obviously been
there from the beginning.
Do you have a sense of the direction?
I have an idea,
you know what I think is
going to happen. Yeah. It's,
everything has got to evolve
or it dies. Right? All right.
And when you talk about the evolution,
there's evolution for fighters,
there's evolution for promoters,
there's evolution for fans as far as what
they get to watch and how they get to
watch it.
And all of that has to evolve for the
sport to continue to rise and build.
When the UFC sold, you know, and
this is no disrespect to anyone.
Look at the greatest thing that
the UFC had was Lorenzo Fertitta.
I'm just being honest.
Dana was fantastic for the UFC as
far as his work effort and the,
the amount of work he
put into it and you know,
nonstop just going after deals. Trying
to make things happen. Right. You know,
he was the workhorse for it, but Lorenzo's
was the brains behind it. You know,
there's a wizard, oh my God.
And the loss of him is great.
Yeah, I agree. It's already, you've
already seen things. Well it's also the,
the issue is the price.
They had to pay $4 billion for
something that's probably worth two.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. I mean, I don't know,
I'm not a business person, but again,
seems like a lot of it.
How did it get, you know,
how did it get to that? Where they,
exactly. Yeah, he's a wizard. He is,
he, you know, and that's, but it is one
of those things that you look and you go,
all right, things have,
they've changed and the,
and the way he went about doing things,
cause look at the one thing that the
Renzo was not afraid of was spending money
right now that's how the UFC survived.
You know,
that here's a guy that gambled and he
was 54 million because he has $44 million
in the hole. And when he then put 10
million more into the ultimate fighter.
Exactly. Yeah. That was a,
that was a time buy and he paid for all
the production and it launched a sport.
Absolutely.
Because you know he deserves everything
that he got from that and he deserves
that giant payout.
No doubt about it.
My concern is that the monthly nut is
so gigantic that I just wonder if like
some people say there's too many fights,
they say there's too many fights,
too many televised fights
and that this is, you know,
this is a part of the problems.
It's oversaturated.
So it's very difficult to sell the
paper views cause people are like, no,
I'm not going to buy this when I
got to watch next week on fs one,
there's a big card. I'm just gonna wait
for that. And that's true. That money,
you look you at it for a while there,
they were almost competing against
themselves with pay per views and it was,
you had to pay per views in a month and
you went and said, I'll buy that one.
I'm not going to buy that one. Yeah. You
can't be in business against yourself.
They got rid of that.
There's also a mistake in the kind of,
especially initially did a lot of
sort of Hollywood style promotion.
Like when I thought there was a real
problem was when Ronda Rousey was making
her comeback against Amanda Nunez and
they weren't even mentioning Amanda Nunez.
Mike, you guys are out of your
fucking mind. Okay. This is the,
this is the woman that
I was saying before.
Rhonda got one that's down by Holly Holm.
I was saying Amanda Nunez is more
dangerous. She's fucking dangerous man.
Especially see or in his last weekend
against Raquel Pennington and like holy
shit just got better and better and
better and better and her fucking
conditioning is off the charts. It's
always a problem for the past. Yeah.
Not Anymore. And come out like a
gang buster and she would fade. Yup.
She's not fading anymore. Just fifth
round. She was coming out guns blazing.
She's a monster man. She has a fucking
monster. So when I was backstage,
I don't know who it was, but I remember
this guy talking and they, they did.
He did not know who Amanda Nunez was.
There's some agent and he said,
whoever she is, she's cannon fodder.
And I remember just going,
what in the fuck are you talking about?
How can you say that?
They were so,
they were hyped up on that video that
they made where Ron is like rottenness
back and she's in this mansion and
wandering on a mansion and watching Amanda
Nunez on TV and like you
guys are out of your mind.
You're out of your mind because it doesn't
matter how many hype pieces you make,
she's still got to fight Amanda
fucking Nunez. That woman is,
she's so good and it fucking power in
our hands is like nobody else in the
division.
Oh I nobody else soldier physically
strong and fast and that creates power.
It's a matter of Raquel Pennington
and you look at it as a tough girl.
She's tough as fuck.
You look at her fight with Holly Holm.
I mean that was the first fight for
UFC and the UFC for Holly and it was a
fucking split decision.
Raquel Pennington is world class and
she's about as tough as it gets. She is
me ask you this,
what did you think after the fourth
round when she said I'm done. And her,
her coach was like, no, you're not done.
You get back in there and you
get back in there. You're gonna,
you're gonna power through. You're going
to, what'd you think of that? Yeah.
And I'm telling you it's wrong for this.
We as fans, as humans, we put way,
way too much emphasis on the
importance of a fight. Okay?
Now it's a,
it's a fight and it's important to that
fighter as they step into that cage for
that first round.
And it's important for them as long as
they are mentally capable of enduring
what is occurring.
Because you know,
fighters go through evolutions
during the fight. They're strong,
they're weak, you know, they're
doing well, they're not doing well.
And once a fighter tells
you, I'm done, it's gone.
Yeah, you're expecting her. Let's
look at what you really have.
She lost four rounds in a row. Okay?
She lost four rounds in the row,
particularly brutal one. Her nose
was shadow. He's got crushed.
Blood was pouring out all over
the place. And you know, again,
for people to understand, let me break
your nose and now let me punch it again.
Okay. You have no concept because
what I'm telling you is, you know,
during a fight, fighters don't
feel pain the way people think.
Cause there's adrenaline and there's
all these things and it's muted.
You feel things and sometimes
you really start to feel him.
And as soon as you really
start to feel them,
you start to lose really bad in that
situation where she had lost four rounds
badly. Okay. So what's going
to happen in the fifth?
You think she's going to come out
with this home run shot. Okay. Okay.
If her mind is still there, maybe,
maybe it, maybe it could happen,
but as soon as she says
I'm done, I want out. Hey,
it's a fight.
And did she received more damage after
that statement in the fifth round?
Oh yeah.
She received more damage.
And what I'm telling you
is it's like you can,
you can have the greatest car in the
world. All right? You can have, you know,
be it, you know, I'm not
a real great car guy,
but a truck that says you're
the raptor Ford Raptor truck.
You can only crash it into the wall
so many times before it says fuck you,
I'm done. Okay. And is not
now no longer a nice truck.
It's a piece of shit. It
doesn't work. Exactly.
And the real question is how much
damage did you do for the rest of Raquel
Pennington's career?
Because she took extra damage and
you never know when it is Joe.
And I can tell you I can,
I can pick out fights where I can tell
you this is the difference in that
fighter from this fine.
In that moment he is no longer the same.
She is no longer the same. And
so as the trainer, what do you,
therefore you are there to get
your fight or ready for the fight.
You're there to be the person that's
helping them during the fight and giving
them instructions and telling them
how to attack person and saying,
you're doing this wrong. I need you
to do this. Whatever it's going to be.
That's your job.
You are there to sometimes motivate them
when they start to lose the belief that
I don't know if I can beat this person
and that happens to everybody. I don't,
I don't know if I can actually, this
person's kicking my ass to be that purse.
Hey, you're doing fine. What I
need you to do is this, you know,
get yourself together. Be that motivator.
But once the fighter tells you,
I'm done, hey, that's the,
mine's gone. It's over.
Don't put them back out there
because they're not going to perform.
They're not going to do well. They can sit
there afterwards and say, Oh, you know,
I'm glad that I went out there. It
didn't change any what, what changed?
The only thing that changed was the
amount of damage that she incurred.
That's it. She defended her
coach after the fight, you know?
But most people would know
and she believes in her
coach and she said it was the
right decision.
But most people that watch that said they
should have stopped the fight. Right.
When she said that,
and I,
and I agree with you and I
think especially when you're
dealing with someone as
tough as her for Raquel Pennington,
I'm a giant fan of hers.
For her to say, I'm done. Like
you, you got to respect that.
When have you ever seen her quit?
Never. Okay. Never. She's just,
she's battered and beaten down and, and
that can happen to anybody. Anybody,
anybody look at it. You know, I mean,
it's so hard to get people to understand.
You have no idea how hard these people
are being hit. You know, people,
people get this idea of, oh,
I could fight with an MMA.
You have no fucking
clue how good they are.
They are dangerous people. And
they hit with power. You know,
when you're actually Nunez, when
you're weak. Well, when you're,
when your cage side or ring side in a
fight and you actually not only see that
shot,
you hear it and you hear the,
the actual impact it's telling you.
Do you realize how hard that
just hit that person, you know,
and they're walking through a lot of those
men and you go, God damned are tough.
Yeah. That's what I tell people
about in Ghana. Like I'm like you,
you think you know what it seems like
when someone hit someone really hard and
they see Francis hit people and he'd go,
oh Jesus,
he's a game changer as far as his power.
Yeah.
It's some new thing going on with
that guy. Some new new thing,
some new thing. I mean a
guy who's got to cut, wait,
a natural guy got to cut weight to get
the [inaudible] 65 and when he hits you,
you literally can't take it. The
only guys being able to do it, right.
But he's done away from everything.
But it's deeply has done it.
And this going into that fight, man, and
this is one of the ones that the UFC,
they were hyping the hell out of
steam out of a Francis. And I go, man,
you are not hyping your champion.
And I'm telling you right now,
if this flight gets out of the first
round, Steve Bay is gonna win it.
I didn't have,
and I'm not the smartest guy in the world,
but it's looking at Steve Bay is the more
complete fighter and look at the guys
that he's fought. Mara can destroyed him.
Yup. Okay. Do you think Mark Hunt can hit?
Yup.
You know it's like don't,
it's not like he hasn't fought guys that
can fricking Bang Junior dos Santos and
destroying y'all have fought him twice.
Overeem drive by Overeem came back,
came back to him out. So he's
demonstrated what he can do. But you're,
you got Francis and he's got that almost
Mike Tyson type of mystique about that
power and I understand that.
Look it,
you just don't see guys hitting upper
cuts at snap. Someone's head back.
My mind can do for that fight.
That was more impressive than anything
Tyson never did because he'd knocked over
him into orbit. Oh my God. Overeem
was completely unconscious.
Toes curled with one shot in a way that
like you just don't see Michael Spinks.
Yeah,
that was speaks,
it already been dropped and he drops
banks and had him hurt and then spanx get
up and he hit him with that right
hand. That was, that was real similar.
But there's something about Frances is
power and if obviously you're dealing
with four ounce gloves, but you're dealing
with a way bigger man too. Absolutely.
Is 40 plus pounds bigger
than Mike near lows? Oh yeah.
Two well to 75 the night of the fight.
Easy compared to no
bigger than not even that.
Probably right to 18 at the both.
Somewhere in there. So yeah, I mean, look,
obviously completely
different sports bikes,
one of the greatest heavyweight
boxers of all time, without a doubt.
But there's something about in Ganos
power that's, it's other worldly. Oh yeah.
It's freakish. Like you see people get
hit and he see this look on their face.
They're like, oh Geez. But you've had
that same look. And no matter if it's,
you're doing kickboxing sparring
or grappling with summer,
and all of a sudden someone's
doing something and you're
like, Holy Shit. Yup, Yup.
There's some holy shit people out there,
man. There's some next level people,
scary people.
Well it makes you think like what would
happen if you got a guy like a Lebron
James,
like a real super athlete and they got
invested in MMA the way Aaron Peko is,
you know, I'll tell you what I did. I
did, uh, he might be too big. There was,
there was a guy named God,
I want to say Golston. Uh,
he was a safety for the
frickin 40 niners and um,
can't remember his first name. I'm an
idiot. But I was doing trading with, uh,
a bunch of NFL players and
MMA guys and just, you know,
getting NFL guys to do martial arts
type training to help with their
flexibility, to help with their
strength, helped with their conditioning.
And I had, frank Trigg was one of the
guys there and then I, and Gholston was,
I had them doing armbars just swinging
hips left to right, left to right.
And you know, crunk, you know, to keep it
for core and he's doing it. I said, no,
look, this is what I want you
to do. Every time you grab this,
I want you to take this and I want
your legs to do this and I want you to
squeeze, right? Just, you know, basic
stuff. And he starts doing it. Frank Goes,
God, God dammit. Thanks John.
Right? I think he's getting cracked.
I mean,
it's pressure.
And then we'd go and we're doing kicking
exercises and I got him up and his back.
I said,
not what?
I want you to take your foot and I need
you to rotate on the ball of your foot.
I need you to do this.
Your foot's going to come right
here and I want it to end up here.
And he starts cracking this bag.
And Joe, I'm like, oh my God.
Could you imagine that this guy wanted
to fight until he got real training? Oh,
gun, talking about Vernon
Vernon goals. He's that guy.
He was, he was a safety for the 40. Niners
and then, uh, then went to Tampa Bay.
Let's just gaze at this man's
physique for a few months.
What in the fuck all men or not,
but that's exactly what gentlemen,
they must be brothers because they
know there's, there's some next level.
W Jamie,
how much do you think Lebron ways?
Probably to 50 oh, six
foot eight. He's not even,
not even too big to fight him.
That's a good question.
What do you think about that weight class?
Like the two 65 weight limit.
It shouldn't heavyweight.
Just be fucking giant. Yeah.
Just should be as big as he can
get. Yup. Yeah. Why is that?
Because he looked and there really should
be something between two oh five and,
well there is, okay, let's, let's,
let's bring this out right now.
There are weight classes that
aren't being used, right? Okay.
They're out there as far as they
are a part of athletic commissions.
They're approved by the ABC.
You've got one 65.
Okay. This is California started this, I
believe Andy Foster, he started as far as,
um, I'm a big fan of that guy. Look at
him. He's outstanding and what he does,
he's proactive. He's trying to
make things right for fighters.
He's absolutely fine. Be Boxed. He
fought MMA. He had a good record. Yup.
You know, he's done it all and he's, he's
officiated, he's done the entire thing.
So He's fantastic for the sport
of boxing and the sport of MMA.
But when you're looking at
everything that, you know,
as far as weights, you know,
we went and said,
look it,
there's 10 pounds between (253) 054-0550
five why are we jumping 15 pounds?
Okay,
let's,
because we have all these guys making
these cuts and there are those guys that
are the tweeners, you know, if
you want to say, you know, Kelvin,
is he a tweener at one 70 to one
75 he could make the one 75 wait,
he can't make the one 70 well he can, he
can't because of the way he does things.
Yeah, he has any can you just can't do
it the way he likes to eat. Exactly.
But he could do with the things he
likes. Yes. Seven 75 yeah, no, I agree.
But in the, this is where, you know,
and this is the UFC is the most powerful
entity with an MMA. And you know,
look at, they've done a ton
of great things for the sport,
but they've also done things that have
held the sport back. Like what? Weight,
weights, weight classes. Because as
soon as we start to come up with, hey,
we're going to do this,
this is going to be a real change.
They're the first ones to go with. What
we've forgotten that UFC used to have,
the weight class was one 90 it wasn't
two oh five when we've changed a lot of
shit.
We first did the unified rules.
Tito Ortiz was the light heavyweight
champion at one 99.9 and as soon as the
unified rules came in and we said,
okay,
that is two five two zero t his was the
light heavyweight champion at two oh
five right. Why don't they
do that? Why don't they?
Because you have some new champions,
have some new championship fights because
you have people that are in a position,
you know, it's like Dana,
it's Dana doesn't know. Okay.
Dana's told things by people because he
can't know everything and when he hears
that, oh, they're talking about
new weight classes, the fur,
he doesn't make a comment about it. He
goes to his people and he says, Hey,
is this a problem for us?
And you have Sean Shelby and Mitt mic.
Maynard are the two matchmakers
for the UFC and they look in the,
they have enough problems as it is
with they're getting everybody to the,
you know,
the fight and making sure that fight
happens and stuff and guys are pulling out
and stuff and they're going to tell
you, oh, we don't want that. Right,
because you're diluting my weight class
now when you're not diluting your weight
class, just move that person here
and move this person. You're,
you're putting them in.
But they're is going to say that you're
diluting it and you're making it too
narrow for them. And so they don't
want that change in the way class.
So Dana goes, we don't want
changes in the way class. Okay.
The sport of MMA needs changes in the
weight class because there's so many
fighters out there that look
at when we make changes,
the change is not for the UFC.
The UFC does not have to have that
weight class if they don't want it.
They can sit there and say,
and the reason that the 170 pound weight
class stayed and remained is because of
the UFC. They said, ah okay, we'll agree
to bringing in more weight classes,
but we want to keep the one 70 cause they
didn't want to move Tyrone Woodley and
they didn't want to have to move their
champions when it's not a big deal,
but when we do a change to the sport,
it's to the sport.
It's not to the UFC, it's not
to Bella tour. It's not two one,
so it's valid to are adding
weight classes. Delta has
an added those either. Okay.
I haven't added them. That's
the promotions. Right.
The promotion can sit there and say,
you know right now Bella tour doesn't
have 125 pound champion there.
They're doing the heavyweight. They
don't even have a heavyweight champion.
Which there will be after the
Grand Prix tournament. So they,
so there's a 55 now there's a 65 to
develop that they move the 70 to 75 70 is
still there at this moment. So right
now he does have a log jam as well.
70 is legal, 75 is legal.
65 is legal. 55 asleep.
I feel like 10 pounds is perfect.
I think that's perfect. It is.
The jumps between like 85 and two oh
five and then it's 2005 and two and
heavyweight to 65 that's
crazy to see by the end.
This is where you get into this.
You know,
everyone gets back into the well hoists.
Gracie fought guys that were bigger.
It's like they didn't know any better
back then. They were clueless. Yeah.
It's a different world when you talk
about size now and when the skill level is
the same and the size is different. I can
tell you who's going to win that fight.
The Bay guys, 100% okay.
Just about every time.
So when you look and you said
if I went and said, okay,
let's take a look at Brock Lesnar
versus Randy couture. Okay.
Brock Lesner is coming in
weighing two 65 for the,
for the Scales and he's two
85 at least for that night.
Radic tourists coming in and
he's two 24 for the scales.
That's what he's going to be
that night. Okay. So we have, eh,
only a 60 pound difference. Okay. So if
I sat sat here right now and said, okay,
I'm going to take Demetrius Johnson
and put him against Chris Weidman,
you're well Romero. Right? Okay. You'd
look at me and go, are you fucking nuts?
Okay. Yeah, because, well that's stupid.
But that's reality of what we do at
times and the heavyweight division.
So we do need something
that is two or five sort of,
you do have smaller heavyweights. We deal
with the percentage of the body size,
that it's far greater percentage of the
body size going from one 25 to one 85
versus biggest percentage is going to
be in that one 55 to one 85 that you've
got more fighters.
One 45 two one 85 what I'm saying to
someone fighting someone was 60 pounds
larger than them when they're 125 pounds
is a way different thing percentage
wise. Yes. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. But
it's, it's that same concept, right?
I could sit there and move it up to 45
still ridiculous that you have a two oh
five to two 65 you have a 60 pound
weight class. That's a crazy, crazy,
but it should be off of, you
know, you got guys that are,
are smaller heavyweights that cut so much
way to get to light heavyweight. Right.
Okay. And that it's not
held at two 25 absolutely.
So you create a to 25 and then
everything else is 55 657585905205 to 25.
You get a little bit of a gap there and
then heavyweight and heavyweight should
be fucking whatever you are. You are,
you know the big, the big, heavy,
heavy, heavy guys. They're
not going to do well anyway.
Remember that guy boxing huge
boxing seven, seven one tall,
gigantic. Who beat him? Did
David? Hey beat him. Did he?
I was um, was it David had to leave
David. Hey beat him and somebody,
which is crazy cause David is, I think
at the end our holy father fought him.
Did he? I think he's wonderful. He
did? Yeah. Wow. Yeah. That's crazy.
Yeah. That guy was almost,
well not almost, he was too
big cause body didn't work.
Right. Look at there is a a point
of diminishing returns. Yeah,
no return. You're going to go down
from that point and to be a big guy,
you can accept more punishment,
but you can only accept it for so long.
I lost the David. Hey,
that was his last fight.
Evander Holyfield David
here where you go see,
oh, he'd beat Evander Holyfield
but he'd beat Holyfield in 2008.
That was a different beat. John
Ruiz, Clifford Clifford it.
Nene let Larry Donald John Ruiz.
Interesting.
He went through some people there
because he's so big. He's a tough, uh,
yeah. I mean just so body to push
against. Yeah. It's just so big.
But I mean it would be interesting to
see what would happen if you let Francis
and gone. Oh, powerlift
yeah. And again, you look
at this and you go, hey,
I would rather see Francis
[inaudible] not cutting weight at all.
You know, and being healthy, being
healthy and stepping in that cage.
This is the thing that people don't
get is when we talk about weight cuts,
you talk about boxing and MMA there,
there are two different sports. One,
I will tell you, MMA is more
violent than boxing. Okay.
Vi more violent because you could pick
somebody up six feet off the ground,
drop them down onto the
surface. Okay. You can pull,
pull someone's arm back to the
point, the elbow hyperextends. Okay.
And to the point where it actually
dislocates that's a more violent but more
damaging is boxing
you team mean overall career
careerwise eet more day. Exactly. Yeah,
because you get hit in the head more.
You've got to target,
I got two tools to targets and 90%
of those blows go to the head. Okay.
But when you're looking at boxers or MMA
fighters and when we have problems with
the weight cuts and we have
problems with subdural Hematomas,
it's always the smaller fighters and it's
because they lose so much weight that
it becomes a problematic thing
with that fight where their,
their brains are dehydrated,
it pulls away from the Dura.
You have all these things that can happen
with bleeding and it cannot stop it
and we get problems from it.
So let's try to get guys in the closer,
credibly unusual for a heavyweight
to die in the ring. And in fact,
I think that guy who fought Luis
Ortiz, remember that Russian cab? Yeah.
That was about what, three
years ago maybe? Yeah.
That was in New York and that guy got
really, really badly hurt and that fight,
and that was one of the rare situations
where a heavyweight experience like
serious brain bleeding got
rushed to the hospital.
He had his cheek crushed
in the second round. Okay.
Imagine fighting and having a heavyweight
boxer punching your face when your
cheek is broken and crushed. Yeah.
All right. Just everything in that,
and this is where sometimes corners need
to stop for you are there to protect
your fight or sometimes from themselves.
They are so tough that doing
the stink of a no moss,
you know that and that,
especially in boxing, look at,
think about when did that fight occur and
it's still talked about 40 years later.
One of the things that Conor McGregor and
Floyd Mayweather was saying during the
fight, Floyd may was said, there's no
tap outs in, does no tap outs in boxing.
Listen Dude, if you got an MMA,
you'd fucking tap out, tap out.
He'd go to sleep or get your arm broken.
And you don't want either one
of those things to happen.
Nope. Yeah, talk is great,
but it's great. I will give them credit
as far as the way they hyped that fight,
it got out of hand at some point. It's
exciting, but you got to look down
at the weigh ins.
Connor with a boner in his underwear.
I don't know what he did
to give himself a boner,
but he's like kind of at least at
least at three quarters. But got a job.
He's got a Chubby and he's screaming
at him in his face like, Whoa,
what is happening here? He was being
attacked from both and angle. Yeah.
Yeah, but it didn't help in the
long run. You knew. Come on.
Anybody think about on that crazy.
Talk about it turned Jane.
Dan has said it's 100% bullshit,
but the crazy talk about Conor and
Floyd fighting in MMA cage with boxing
gloves. No kicks, no
takedowns, no submissions.
But you can clinch. It's
ridiculous because the clinch
is going to do you what?
Good in that you can
dirty box and you know,
I'm going to tell you,
Connor has the ability to dirty box better
than Floyd because Floyd is not used
to doing it. It's a different
element. But look it,
if you're going to come
into another man's sport,
quit trying to change the rules.
Yeah. Just come into this.
Carter went into his sport.
He didn't change the rules.
Now he did some things illegally.
I'll give him that. You know,
he's hitting it with a hammer fist. He's
doing things. You Go, you can't do that.
Right. But for the most part,
he's following those rules part.
Okay.
Oh,
you'd have to do is just say no take
downs and no submissions and no glasses
before that first one. Go ahead.
Before the first one I said, no,
I don't want to see Conor box.
And I said, tell you what,
let's make it halfway even. Yup.
Kickboxing. Yeah. Okay. No take downs.
No Brown. But he gets to get kicked.
It would have changed that fight.
Oh fuck yeah. Yeah. But
you know, Floyd smart,
I don't blame him for doing what you know.
And he's a moneymaking machine.
He's smart and he's not going to
do anything stupid. If anything,
he'll wait for some other box to get
really pop or other MMA fighter to get
really popular and box
him. Smart man. I mean,
he literally might not ever
box a boxer again. I mean,
he made his biggest pay day ever fighting
a guy was zero zero zero professional
boxer boxing fights. Pretty
crazy. It's absolutely crazy.
What was his payout,
would they say? Overall,
it was like something more the
hundred million, $300 million.
That's a good piece of change.
That'll,
that'll tide him over for about two
years and I'm not even kidding. Hey,
that guy spends money like water.
It's crazy. He does. He's crazy.
He's fun to watch though. It's fun
to watch you spend all that money to,
it's like Jesus Christ. You know? I
watch him split it. I cringe. Yeah,
I can't. It's like, oh, I can't,
I can't even believe that you're
paying that money for that. Why?
It's like every gets like that broke.
They all go
broke. It's just a matter of time. That's
what I don't want to see. Yeah, but don't,
Ya know, isn't it kind of fun? I mean,
is it terrible that he has to get a job
like regular folks? He's a terrible,
I mean, what, what is tig? There's
something about that, right?
If we give you go to a fucking
job site and you see a guy,
I was working as a finished carpenter,
you don't go,
poor guy's got to work as a
finished carpenter. He'd go,
hey man, what's going on?
He goes, hey, how you doing? Everybody's
fine. Everybody's fine with that.
But if that guy used to be
Floyd Mayweather and now
he's working as a finished
carpenter. Is that poor
bastard? Oh, amber, those
nails. No. No. What's it like?
Oh yeah. Oh yeah, I hit that.
Oh yeah. That you fucking loser.
You used to be on top of the world. Sure.
To spit all the fucking money, Floyd.
Right? Isn't that weird? It's
a weird thing that people do.
I used to work with a guy named Mike
Quarry. I remember Mike Pori Corey. Sure.
And you know Mike was a professional
boxer like every way, right? Absolutely.
Fuck Bob Foster for the man
we title back in the day.
I used to dig holes with my query.
Wow.
I used to do plumbing with him and he was,
he was a great guy, but he was a mess.
I mean punch drunk. Oh yeah, absolutely.
And his brother was even worse,
but you know, it couldn't, he couldn't,
you know, couldn't wheel a wheelbarrow.
They didn't have the balance
and coordination to do any more.
But if you put him in and I would spar
with him, we'd go in and we would,
we would work out and you put them in a
ring and all of a sudden he started to
bounce.
He could fight still.
It was just part of who that
ability to do it. Exactly.
He carved. Yep. And it's, you know, and
it's, but it's sad because, you know, he,
he ended up leaving that and he ended
up going, he tried to become a, uh,
a haircutter tried to become a blouse.
Yeah. He tried to become a barber.
He cut his thumb off, you know, all
day. And you're looking at go, it's sad.
You know,
it's like he had had to do those things.
Cause though is that he's physically
damaged and he can't move right and can't
talk right and all that stuff. But is it
Saturday has to work a regular job? No,
that's not sad.
But it's sad when you look and you say
he could have gotten away with that if
you just saved all that money.
If you,
if someone was smart enough
to tell you back then look it,
I want you to take this
much and put it here.
Maybe you wouldn't have to be doing
this today. And you look at, you know,
his whole thing,
his way his dad was with him and you know
with the things he went through, it's,
you look and you go,
I feel bad.
I feel bad that you're having to
come in here everyday like I am.
But after what you've
done in your life and the,
and the status that you actually had
at one time, yeah, I feel bad. Yeah,
you feel bad. But if he was just a
regular guy, you wouldn't feel bad.
That's where it's weird. That's fucking
weird. It's a weird thing, right? It is.
You know, it's, we, we, we elevate people,
but it's also nobody really wants to
work. Right. Very few of you love work.
Not a regular job. I don't
know. You're working at bell.
Tore your fucking commentator. Stop. Okay.
Stop. Hold on. I want to send me my job.
I told you that's easy. I want you to
think of it. This is my third career. Yes.
Okay.
I was a police officer. He loved
that too. Okay. I loved it.
I had a ball doing it and then I had
a career as a referee. Basically.
I loved it. I still do. You know,
don't think that I wouldn't like to
go and still do fights and stuff and,
and I watch a fine. God Damn,
I wish I was sitting there.
Why can't they let you do both? It doesn't
make any sense to me. Ah, you know,
I was running shit.
I will absolutely let you do both,
but this is the differences,
you know,
MMA and boxing or set up
completely different than
any other sport as far as how
they're run, you know, the NFL, you know,
this is why I tried to say this with,
you know,
people wanting to come into
officiating for the MMA. And the,
the big questions I get is, you
know, oh, how much, you know,
how long will it take and
how much can I make? Okay.
Then my first response is get
the fuck away from me. Okay.
Because you don't get it
in. And this is, and I tell,
I tell guys that are doing
it. I said, hey, let me,
let me explain what this is to
you. And it's, you know, you,
you get paid for doing what you do and I
don't know what it is and I don't care,
but you deserve it.
But tell me what it's like for
Joe Rogan to walk into an arena.
Some of the biggest arenas in the
world. Madison Square Garden, you know,
t-mobile staples, no one stops you,
they don't fricking hold you back.
You get to walk anywhere you want in
that arena, you get to walk to the cage.
If you want to walk in the back and go
to the locker rooms, you can do that.
No one stops you.
You don't pay a dime for it.
And you get to sit and watch the greatest
fights in the world. Good Gig. Hello.
It's priceless. It's
priceless. Yeah, I enjoy it.
And it's exactly it because you love the
sport and it's not about how much money
you make.
It's about being a part of something and
being able to do something that other
people would give their left
fucking nut for sure. You know?
And the other one that I'm
talking to them, I like,
how much have you done to prepare
yourself for this? Because look at,
I started doing stuff
back when I was a kid.
Now I didn't do it to prepare to be an
official that just fell into my lap.
But all the stuff that my dad made made
me do. Okay, I'll, you know, doing,
you know, anything that you know,
had to do with combative sports.
And then from there continuing
on and then you know,
meeting Horian Gracie and going and
learning that and all of that set me up to
have the ability to be successful at
this sport where I tell people all the
time, look at it, let's,
let's look at the NFL.
You want to be an official and you
want to do the Superbowl. Great.
Because the UFC is the NFL,
two fighters and two
officials. Okay. It should be,
but they're looking at it and they go,
I get people all the time saying,
oh I could do that. You know, I
would be great. I know I'd be,
I've been watching since
the beginning and you go,
you have no fucking clue because
if you want to do this in the NFL,
how would you go about doing it?
Well you'd start off in peewee
football with little six year olds,
eight year olds doing,
you know,
officiating on the weekends and you would
do that for a couple of years and then
you graduate to a higher level.
And then finally you might even get to
high school and from high school you
might even get into junior
college and junior college.
You might start doing division three,
division two.
You might make it to Division One and
by the time they call and say, Hey,
do you want to come here and start
to do summer league for the NFL?
You've put in 15 to 20
years of officiating and of
going through problems and
situations and everything and that's the
big difference that people don't get.
Even the athletic commissions,
they all will have somebody that has
been their guy at their state who is,
well, he's there for all our small
shows and he, oh, he's always, you know,
he's always available and
he's always doing stuff,
so we want to give them that bigger
shot and the UFC is coming here.
We want to put them in that
main event fight and you go,
don't do it to them because they have
no concept that when that official steps
into that octagon for that
very first prelim fight,
their heart rate's at about 145
beats per minute just standing still.
Why the adrenaline's flowing and
they're scared. They're scared because,
oh my God, I can't make a mistake because
now I've got all these eyeballs on me.
All right,
and that's where you get all of that
knowledge is doing the small shows and
going through time and had seeing,
you know, having problems yourself,
seeing other people have those problems.
How do they deal with it?
Talking to other officials,
what do you do in this situation?
That's where that experience is going to
help separate you from the other people
and when the bad thing happens, you make
it look easy. Sometimes it's not easy.
Sometimes you don't make it look easy.
Sometimes it's just as a mess,
but it's that experience that's going
to get you out of the problem without
everyone wanting to take your head.
Yeah,
it's always an issue or it
was an issue for a while.
At least when we would go to a new town
and they would do local guys in the
local guys would have to referee.
They wanted a certain percentage of local
guys refereeing fights and local guys
would do big high level fights
and make gigantic mistakes. Yup.
And separate guys when they were working
and separate guys when they were on the
ground and people would go crazy,
including me, I would go crazy too.
Well that's because you're expecting
how certain level of competence in doing
that job and well, I've seen it done
this way multiple times, multiple times.
All of a sudden boom, something
different now it goes whoa. Right.
And arbitrary subjective decisions that
affect professional fighters careers.
If it's not fair, if I win and
I put you with official, I said,
I explained to me when you stand
somebody up, when you don't, right,
they're not going to do a good job of it.
Okay. I'll tell you exactly why I do it.
When I would do it, why I
wouldn't. Okay. Because you get,
you know there's positions and
you know what they are. I mean,
when a guy takes somebody down, it's not
easy to get somebody down. Okay? Now,
if I'm the guy getting taken
down and I close my guard,
grab a hold of him gable grip, pull him
in tight. Let's see, what am I doing?
I'm stalling on the guy
underneath stalling this fight,
trying to get stood up because I wanted
to get stood up because I have a referee
that's going to stand me up because
the crowd starts to go, boo. Well,
I'm not being fair if,
if I'm the referee in this situation,
I'll never stand you up.
I'm going to give that guy in the top
position all the time in the world to get
past what you're doing. As long
as he's working, trying to do it,
it's when he starts to stall in the top
position and not try to do anything and
just sit there. Now you're stalling to
stop stand up, but from a lot guard,
Dale Grit. What submissions
do I have? Nothing.
What did you think of this past
weekend with John Fitch and Paul Daley?
We're Paul Daley was yelling out booboo.
You know that that was a strange,
strange scene.
What is it come on to you?
What is it?
He was very frustrated with his inability
to stop. John Fitches game. Yeah.
John Fitch game is obvious
to everybody that watches,
he wants to take you down and pound.
And was there any,
was there any doubt in your mind what
John Fitch is going to try to do in that
fight? Okay, so if you're Paul Daley,
is there any doubt in your mind what
John Fitch is going to try to do in this
fight and isn't any doubt would Paul
dailies can to try to do exactly right.
Okay,
so because the fact that I
can't stop what he does now,
I'm just going to sit there and you know,
boo, I'm breaking mentally. I broken.
I can't stop what he's doing and
so I'm going to try it. It was,
he booing about the matchmaking. He boot
about everything. He booed John. He said,
you know, you're not fired. He booed
a bellatore. He booed the crowd.
He pooed everything because you know,
there's that point where we all,
you know, I can't get out of this.
Why doesn't Paul daily just kickbox.
You know what?
I talked to him before the fight
and he seemed like he was, you know,
mentally better off and he was
happy. And you look and you go, hey,
you know what you're getting
yourself into. I mean, here's a guy,
when you look at it, Joe, he really
has 32 knockouts in 40 victories.
You know what he's going to do.
Okay.
And he has explosive
lefthand from hell man,
his left hand when it hits you and I
don't care where it hits you h in the top
of the head, even block it,
you know, so you know what
he's gonna do. And it's like,
if you don't want to be that guy,
that can be taken down,
stop doing this sport because this is
part of the sport. It is not a matter of,
well, I th I want to be able to fight
standing up because it's more exciting.
Have you ever talked to him about, I have.
What does he say? Yeah, he goes, he says,
I just use the grappling is boring.
Then stop it. Wait a minute.
The grappling is boring. Well, why does
it need just kickbox alo? And he has,
he has, he kickbox to when they
have the dynamite card. Yeah,
but why doesn't he just do that? I
mean, he's a fucking dynamite striker.
He is a phenomenal kickboxer. But there's
a difference. You know, I, and I'm,
you know, you know, look, you can
take some kickboxers out there. Okay.
And put them in an MMA fight.
They're in trouble. Yeah, but man,
you put them in a kickboxing fight.
Those dudes are phenomenal.
And just the fact that what they do,
they cannot do in an MMA cage because
the ability for them to be taken down,
it stops them from trying to do some
of those things. Well, with Paul,
Paul is that guy, he's the, he's
the high level striker in MMA.
Put 'em in kickboxing against some
certain guys. Hey, you know what?
There's guys out there,
they're going to,
he's going to wish you could go to
the ground. Let's just be honest.
He's that guy. He's kind of in the
Middle Lane. He's a tweener. Yeah,
man.
I just phenomenal fighter.
But I feel like if he fully concentrated
on kickbox and maybe that would be the
thing. Yeah, it's just, to me it doesn't
make any sense. Like I was watching that.
I was like, man, this is like
career implosion. Watching
him. I felt bad for him.
I really did.
You know?
And I felt bad for him not because
he was losing the fight. Right.
I feel bad for him that you know what?
You're making such bad choices.
That was a bad choice and enjoying things.
Ultimate frustrated.
It just makes you look bad.
I mean,
he's just stuck in this situation where
he just doesn't seem like he can get out
of it, you know? And look at it when he,
in the end of the first round
and when he went after John, hey,
no one's sitting there saying, stop. Let's
put you on the ground. Right. Of course.
Okay. Because you have an advantage
here. You're utilizing that advantage.
Good for you.
But John fought the exact fight that
you would expect him to try to fight
against a guy like Paul Daley. I mean,
it's amazing that John is still swinging.
He looks better. John looked
better physically, mentally,
everything.
He,
he had a lot of problems and I talked to
him about those problems and you know,
he was messed up. His neck was completely
screwed up. He actually switched,
you know, he talked about it. He goes,
I had to switch to a southpaw to fight
Jake shields because if I got hit
standing right handed, I got hit.
My head went that way. He goes,
my entire arm would go numb and
I couldn't feel it. Whoa. Yeah.
And there was a lot of things. He says it.
He goes, I've, I've got all that fixed.
And he did. He's fixed it and not through
surgery. He had doctors telling him,
you need surgery.
And he's done it through physical therapy,
exercise and nutrition that he believes.
He goes,
I don't have the same problems anymore.
He said, he goes, I was taking,
I was utilizing a lot of
marijuana to take care of painter.
I don't do that anymore. You
know, he's a, that's a pity.
But I know a, he tried veganism for
a while, but he said it made him,
made him feel weak and then went back
to eating meat and he said that really
made him feel better. And then I know
he'd gone through a bunch of things,
but I wasn't aware of
his neck injury big time.
So it was a bulging disc or
something along those lines.
Stenosis and bulging disc and big problems
with he would get hit and his entire
side would go. And how did he fix
that? I mean, what could you know,
in talking to him, he said, I, I've,
I started doing a nutritional and he says,
I take like 40 different
pills a day that he's,
I wish I could, I wish I could
remember the guy who said them.
I don't mean medication.
No. Yeah, supplements,
supplements for bone things and,
and opening of,
of uh, blood vessels and
all these different things.
I'd love to hear about that.
It's really interesting.
It is interesting and it's,
it's great that he was able to find that
person that what this guy told them to
do has worked for them. Well, you know,
Jake had gone through a similar situation.
He had a back injury and the doctors
are telling them to stop fighting.
They would tell him, stop fighting. Stop.
That's, well that's, that's a doctor's,
you know thing all the time. You
can't do it anymore. You know,
and you can sit there at any paths.
He hands a movie actually.
But I know the actual scene. I know
what actually really happened to Vinny,
you know, with a broken neck. Yeah. I mean
they told them you're done. He's like, no,
I'm not. Yeah, he went on to have some
of his best fights. Absolutely. Yeah.
But then again, sometimes
you are done. I mean it's,
it's hard to make that distinction.
Like when do you know when your body is
broken to the point of no repair? Well,
you know, it comes down to everyone. I
don't care who you know, you, me, anybody,
you know the difference
between you physically now
at the age of 50 compared to
what you physically could do
at the age of 30 you know,
there's a big difference and it just,
you know, father time's undefeated,
beat starts to go and everything
starts to go mentally.
You're way smarter now. Well,
that's why TRT was so dangerous.
Like the TRT v toward days.
You got a guy who's 37 years old,
much smarter,
who's also hopped up on apple sauce and
throwing fucking wheel kicks at people.
And there's just a different,
he was a different animal because he
had so much knowledge behind them,
but his body was moving like a young man's
body. Yup. Yeah. Which is interesting.
It's like you're, you're
hacking father time. You're,
you've got all that knowledge,
wisdom and discipline. Look at it.
The more knowledge you have,
the better off you are.
And I have a whole lot of old
[inaudible] stories when he was young,
when look at it, he was mentally God.
God gives everybody certain things,
but very rarely does he give
them everything you know.
But physically he blessed VTR.
Physically Vittorio was fast.
Oh yeah. He had good strength.
He was, you know, balance wise, he was
great. All kinds of credible. Yeah.
But up here, that was where he was
lacking. It wasn't that he was stupid,
but he lacked confidence and he would
have to have people telling him that he
could do stuff all the time. And because
he never believed in himself. Later on,
he started to believe in himself. He
started, he matured. And you know, that's,
that's what a successful person does.
Yeah. I mean that's a thing too,
that people have to realize those low
points in your life where you don't
believe in yourself. That doesn't define
you. That's just you at that moment.
And you can improve on that.
So many people just go through
this life thinking who they are,
is who they will be forever. Know who
you are is what you make. Yeah. I mean,
if that's the case,
like I'd still be that fucking
idiot who I was in high school.
I was on big idiot. Everybody was,
I'm embarrassed by this stuff I
used to do.
Of course you shouldn't be in is like,
just knows Christ what an
ass I was. Especially people
that have a lot of energy,
right? You have a lot of
energy and enthusiasm. You
make giant colossal mistakes.
Then you're like raw and then you think
about yourself. You're like, is that me?
You're not even the same person you were
a year ago. He no one is your, your con.
If you're paying attention and you're
learning from life's mistakes and life's
decisions and all the
trials and tribulations,
you should theoretically at least be
improving in the way you approach life
every day. You really should be.
Should be, and then with fighting,
those things are highlighted because
you only fight if you're lucky two,
three times a year, you
know, unless your, you know,
Jeremy Horn and he was fighting
all over the place and you know,
or Travis Walton. Hello. I think Travis
is well over 200 fights now, right?
He's still fighting while he
fights boxing, I've done it.
I've done boxing matches with the brazy
how many fights that guy has and he
seems fine. He is. That's
nuts. That's genetics.
There's certain people, I don't care
what anyone wants to say. Oh, it's true.
There's certain people that they're
predisposed. If they get head trauma,
they're going to have problems
and there are certain people do.
You could hit him in the
head with everything you
have for as long as you want
and they're just going to be
fine. Yeah, there's a certain,
there's certain guys that one or two
knockouts and they're basically done.
It's just one or two that was
Freddie Roach look at, you know,
if you go back and use, you know,
Eddie Fudge was Freddy Roach.
His trainer he flushed was the trainer
for Joe Frazier during his, you know,
like Thrilla in Manila against,
uh,
Muhammad Ali and Eddie fetches the one
that pulled Joe Frazier out of that fight
when he was winning the fight in the,
between the 14th and 15th round, right?
When Muhammad Ali was going to say,
I can't go back out there and Eddie Fudge
because Joe Frazier couldn't see, says,
you're done.
I'm not going to let you back out there
because he cared when it's the right
thing. But he was the trainer of
Freddie Roach and Freddie Roach.
I think it was 14 to know
when he lost his first fight.
And you watch at that point
when he gets knocked out,
Eddie Fudge told him, son,
you're done. You don't,
you shouldn't fight anymore because
he's seeing something in him now.
Freddie Roach goes,
you're crazy.
I lost one fight and he goes with
somebody else and starts to add,
but he progressively goes down.
His box can goes away and he probably
saw something in the gym as well.
Absolutely he did. Cause it's every
day that he's with me. You can see it,
you know,
and it's a hard thing man.
Cause you care about that person
and it is part of your livelihood.
You're working with them.
You do get paid through them,
but you do care about that person.
You don't want to see him go
down and you know that happens.
How's it for you when you were being
a referee and you were seeing guys who
probably shouldn't be doing anymore?
Kills me.
People when it comes to refereeing,
what they don't understand
is you're responsible.
Okay.
You're that last level of responsibility
for the fighters and the on the,
the, the matchmakers put the
fight together. You know,
the promoter promotes that fight.
The Athletic Commission
approves that fight and then
puts you in there with them.
And you know,
I can tell you there's sometimes they
give you what I call a shit sandwich.
You know, this is bad from the beginning,
but you deal with it and you handle it.
But what people, what fans don't
understand is, you know, as a,
as a reference,
I never care.
There's only been one time that I
ever cared who want to fight. Okay.
One time. What was that?
Marilla Bustamante versus
Matt Lindland. I screwed up.
I screwed up and trust me
from that point. Well, I'll,
I'll explain it real quick. Matt Lindland,
uh, got caught in an arm bar, tapped,
said he didn't tap. You listen to
him, you said, okay, go back again.
He's like Jesus Christ. And then you
realize you'd made this big mistake, huge.
Matt Lindland who was a great competitor
but maybe perhaps a little bit over
enthusiastic about the outcome, was
willing to bend the rules a little bit.
And that's his job. I don't
have a problem with that. Sure.
The problem is the referee
who is not decisive too bad,
cause I, I second guessed
myself and I said, oh my God,
cause it wasn't a tab so enthusiastic
about adamant about John. I did not.
And it's like, did I
make a mistake? Right.
And at the time I could have
no instant replay and I,
well I couldn't put them back in the,
even in the same position because at
the time if I interfered with the fight,
the rule said that I must put them to
their corners and restart the fight.
Wow. So you just ate it. Oh
yeah. Well you just ate it.
Marillo eight it really felt horrible.
He came back,
he came another full round, I believe
it went into that next round. Yeah. Yup.
Yeah.
And I felt dude to this day
that still drives me crazy.
But really it was a guy that people
forget. Oh, he was one of the very,
another crossing guy, but just
phenomenal Jujitsu. Just, I mean,
when he was in his prime,
when he was at UFC middleweight champion,
he left the UFC as the middleweight
champion, I believe. No.
Did he lose the title in the UFC?
I'm trying to release too.
I feel like you left as champion.
He might of,
I think he left his champion and went
to pride. If I remember correctly.
I'm foggy on this guys. He got beat
by Dan Henderson in pride. Yup. Yeah.
He might've walked out, walked
away and gone there. You're
right. But he, you know,
he was never,
when he fought big Tom Erickson,
that fucking started.
See,
they're right there at that
fight and people talk about
the rules and that fight.
There's a rule because of it. Yeah. When
you sit there and you have a fighter,
you had Tom Erickson being
the big 290 pound wrestler.
He was fucking huge. The
cat, big cat against Marillo.
He goes to the ground with
Marillo and goes, fuck that.
I'm not going to be on the ground. This
cow, I'm in danger. He gets up and says,
I'm going to be a boxer. And rural is
like, I don't want to stand up with that.
I do hits hard for it too.
You may not be good with what he's doing,
but he's still hits hard.
And I remember when he knocked out
Kevin Randleman in Brazil. Oh yeah.
Ooh Tom. Eric starts
fucking bang. Oh yeah.
But Marillo is chasing him on his
butt and Erickson's backing away.
It looked horrible. So we said at that,
that was when we came up with, look at,
we've got to have one fighter in control
of it. The person that's standing,
if they back away from their opponent
and you'll know to this day you watched
fighters, you see the referee
coming and you got to get up.
That was like a three hour, I mean, not a
three hour, 30 minute fight right there,
isn't it? It's one of those crazy ones.
Yeah, it was. It was. It was horrible.
But it taught us a lot.
Wasn't that the same event?
We're all [inaudible]
up kicked or a hands up,
hands up kicked Olig
tech tar off Mars event.
Mars event.
Would that stand for martial arts reality.
Super fights.
Why do people like that?
I tried to get away from an
LAPD cause that's all they did.
Well because the UFC is so good.
It's such a good acronym.
That's an [inaudible] an acronym though.
That's just the initials, that piece,
right? You're right, you're right.
It's not like Mars. The just,
what is it called when it's not in
an acronym and it's three to just an
abbreviation. What is it? No,
it's like NFL. What is that
called? I forget that word.
I just learned. I never, I
never know that word. Um,
but people just try to recreate
something like that. You know,
they try to the IFC or whatever the
fuck they try to come up with something.
Well you look,
you'd talk to Lorenzo and you know his
thing was in the end I bought three
letters. Yeah. About the U
F C and the Octagon. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause all this day, right? Bell
has to use a circle. Circles better.
Ooh, no, that has nothing to talk.
And Chat has nothing to do with,
it has nothing to do with us.
You talk about your basketball court?
Well, any corner creates a problem.
I get it.
So the circle at least is there's nothing
different in any section of that to
where that those two points come
together for the the octagon.
I can see that logic and it's no,
I still look at the safest environment
for fighters is actually the cage because
it contains them.
If you watch Bella toward kickboxing,
you see that what they do is they do a
kickboxing and an MMA show in the same
night.
Same Day.
I was just going to say that I think
they do the best ring for boxing and why?
Well, I can't fall out of it. When Bernard
Hopkins and his last price minutes,
Joe Smith,
he got knocked out and fell through and
hit his fucking head on the ground. Yeah,
it was a terrible law.
I mean this is the guy who was
one of the greatest of all time,
but you'd look at the ropes compared
to the end of the not much space.
It's ridiculous. Whereas the ring
sitting in the belt or cage circle,
there's plenty of room every fall say
roof. It's all safe. Yup. Yeah, I agree.
I think it's smart, but she'll
get promoters that don't want that
because it takes away seating. Ah,
based on the ground sisters. Yup.
Monsters. It's crazy. But that's the way
they are. Well, listen, big John. Uh,
glad we finally got a chance to do this.
It's been a pleasure to be your friend.
It's been a pleasure knowing you all
these years and you are the Oge of ogs.
Thank you. I appreciate it. Let's
do this again sometime. Absolutely.
And congratulations on
your success with valador.
I think you're doing a great
job over there and I really,
I'm happy they're doing really well too.
Thank you brother. I appreciate it, man.
Big John McCarthy.
Motherfuckers respect.